FISCAL REVIEW WILL COME TO
ORDER GOOD AFTERNOON A RESPONSE
THE CODE NINETEEN EMERGENCY TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC. WE ARE
LIMITING OUR GATHERINGS IN A
HEARING TO SOCIAL DISTANCING
AND FACE COVERING GARMENTS AND-
SO WE'VE ADJUSTED VARIOUS
PRACTICES TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PUBLIC CAN STILL PARTICIPATE.
WE'RE HOLDING THIS COMMITTEE
HEARING HERE IN THE CAPITAL.
BUT OUR REPRESENTATIVES FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S
OFFICE WILL BE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. AND SO- I KNOW MY
FOLKS IN- BOTH THE- ELLIE- AND
DEPARTMENT FINANCE KNOW HOW DO
YOU. USE THE- MUTE AND UNMUTE
RATHER YOU JUST I. NEED BUT I.
T. WILL PUT YOU BACK ON ME. SO
TO ALLOW PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS. THE ROOM
THAT WE'RE MEETING IN RIGHT NOW
IN AN OVERFLOW ROOM AND WE'RE
ALSO USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY. I'M
GONNA GIVE YOU THAT PHONE
NUMBER NOW. BUT IT IS ALSO ON
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE THE
PARTICIPANT NUMBER TO CALL IN
IS. 877-336-4437 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS. EIGHT TWO SIX EIGHT
FOUR TWO EIGHT. AND IF YOU NEED
INSTRUCTIONS FOR HOW TO USE IT
YOU CAN GO TO THE SENATE BUDGET
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IN ORDER TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY. THE PRECIADO. I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WELL EVERY
EFFORTS BEEN MADE TO STREAMLINE
OUR PROCESSES AND CONDUCTOR
HEARINGS IN THE SAME MANNER AS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIMES. DUE TO THE TECHNOLOGY
AND WE ASK THAT YOU BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO
EVERYONE CAN BE HEARD. TELLING
ME SEE IF I'VE GOT A QUORUM YET.
NOT YET. SO WE'RE GOING TO
START AS A SUBCOMMITTEE- AND-
JUST AS SOON AS WE SEE MORE
MEMBERS COME DOWN WE WILL I
WILL ASK OUR CONSULTANT MR
STEPPING SHOT TO COLD RULE AND
THEN WE'LL ESTABLISH A QUORUM.
BUT TODAY IS OUR LAST BUDGET
HEARING BEFORE THE SUMMER
RECESS SCORES WERE GOING TO DO
THAT PRETTY SOON- AND THE GREAT
NEWS IS. THAT IT IS ALMOST ALL
NOT ALL BUT MOST ALL OF THE
TRAILER BILLS BUT WILL TAKE UP
TODAY ARE ALMOST ALL OF THE
TRAILER BILLS THAT WE'RE GOING
TO NEED TO CONTINUE TO ACT. IN
ORDER TO- MAKE THIS BUDGET THAT
WE HAVE ALREADY ADOPTED
COMPLETE THERE ARE SOME THINGS
WE WILL BE DOING IN THE- AFTER
WE GET BACK FROM RECESS- BUT-
SOME OF THE CORE ONES ARE HERE
THAT WE'RE HEARING TODAY THERE
ARE ELEVEN BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA. AND AS A REMINDER THE
BUDGET BILL THAT IS ASSOCIATED
WITH THESE WE PASSED ON JUNE
TWENTY EIGHTH- AND LET ME GO
THROUGH VERY QUICKLY THESE WHAT
THESE TRAILER BILLS ARE DEAD
THE STATE MAKE THE STATUTORY
CHANGES NECESSARY TO IMPLEMENT
MANY OF THE MAJOR COMPONENTS OF
THAT JUNE TWENTY EIGHTH BUDGET
AGREEMENT AND THEY ARE THE
MEDICAID EXPANSION TO ALL
INCOME ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIANS
FIFTY PLUS YEARS OF AGE. THE WE
ARE ELIMINATING THE ACID TEST
FOR SENIORS WITH PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES ESTABLISHING THE
YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE AND THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CONTINUUM WELL I LOOKS
LIKE BEFORE I CONTINUE WE MIGHT
HAVE A QUORUM SO I WILL
CONTINUE DESCRIBING THOSE
TRAILER BILLS IN A MOMENT BUT I
WILL ASK OUR CONSULT MR
STEPHENS SHOT TO PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL AND LET'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. WITH SENATORS ARE
SCANNER I'M HERE SKINNER HERE
NELSON. LISTEN HERE COPYRIGHT.
CORTESE DOLLY DOLLY HERE TO
RAZA. THE RAZA HERE RAZA HERE
EGGMAN A MAN HERE GROWTH COM
LONGER. BLAIR LEHRER HERE
MAGUIRE MELINDA'S MAN MAN HERE
NEWMAN NEWMAN HERE A TROUBLED.
TEN YEARS PENN HERE STERN WHY
CASKEY MY CASKEY HERE. PFIZER
WE HAVE ESTABLISHED A QUORUM SO
LET ME RETURN TO BUT LET ME
BEFORE I GO THROUGH THE MY KIND
OF LIST OF TRAILER BILLS. I
JUST WANT TO REMIND US WE'VE
OBVIOUSLY THIS. BUT TO PROCESS
THIS YEAR BECAUSE OF THE
ENORMITY OF THIS BUDGET. IT IS
THE LARGEST BUDGET WE'VE EVER
ADOPTED IN FOR EXAMPLE AS WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT BEFORE IT HAS THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF FUNDING FOR
UNDER PROP NINETY EIGHT FOR K.
THROUGH TWELVE SCHOOLS FOR
EXAMPLE. AND IT IS SO MANY
OTHER COMPONENTS THAT WE'VE HAD
A NUMBER OF BUDGET HEARINGS
WHERE WE HAVE BEEN ADOPTING
TRAILER BILLS IN ORDER TO PUT
THE STATUTORY THINGS IN PLACE
TO DEAL WITH THE APPROPRIATIONS
WE MADE BUT THE FACT THAT WE'VE
BEEN DOING IT- IN YOU KNOW IN-
IN THESE DIFFERENT HEARINGS I
THINK CAN SOMETIMES- BECAUSE
FOLKS TO SERVE DILUTE. THE
INCREDIBLE ENORMITY OF THIS AND
THE TRANSFORMATIONAL ASPECT OF
THIS BUDGET WHICH I PERSONALLY
AND JUST VERY VERY HAPPY
PLEASED AND THRILLED ABOUT.
AND- I WILL REPEAT NOW. WHAT
THESE TRAILER BILLS WILL DO
WHICH COMMUNICATE SOME OF THE
TRANSFORMATIVE ASPECTS OF THIS
PROJECT WHICH IS. IN THE HEALTH
AREA OUR TRAILER BILLS WILL
ALLOW US TO ESTABLISH THIS
YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE AND BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CONTINUUM INFRASTRUCTURE
PROGRAM. THAT WILL ALLOW US TO
EXPAND MEDICARE ALL FOR ALL OF
OUR INCOME ELIGIBLE
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE FIFTY
YEARS AND OLDER. IT WILL
ELIMINATE THE ACID TEST FOR OUR
SENIORS AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. AND THEN IN THE
SOCIAL SERVICES AREA THOSE
FOLKS IN CALIFORNIA WHO ARE
DEPENDENT ON SS P. GRANTS WILL
GET THERE. THEIR MONTHLY
STIPENDS RACED. IT ALSO ENDS
FOR GOOD THE USE OF OUT OF
STATE PLACEMENTS FOR
CALIFORNIA'S FOSTER CHILDREN SO
WE ARE GOING TO AS WE SHOULD BE
TAKE CARE OF OUR FOSTER
CHILDREN HERE IN THE STATE IT
ALSO GREATLY EXPANDS FINANCIAL
AID TO HELP PUT US ON A PATH
TOWARDS DEBT THREE COLLEGE AND
FOR MANY IT DOES SOMETHING VERY
VERY IMPORTANT WE KNOW WHEN THE
TIME OF THIS PANDEMIC THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF ECONOMIC
UPHEAVAL. WE KNOW THAT LOTS OF
DIFFERENT SECTORS ARE GOING TO
PERMANENTLY CHANGE AND MANY OF
THE- KINDS OF JOBS THAT SOMEONE
MAY HAVE RELIED ON BEFORE IT
MATE THERE MAY BE FEWER OF THEM
AND SO WE'VE ALWAYS
TRADITIONALLY HAD. R. CAL
GRANTS FINANCIAL AID TIED TO
YOU HAD TO IF YOU IF YOU'RE
GOING TO GO TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGE THE ONLY WAY YOU GET
THAT FINANCIAL AID IS IF YOU
WENT WITHIN A FEW YEARS AFTER
HIGH SCHOOL IF YOU'RE UNDER A
CERTAIN AGE. NOW WE RECOGNIZE
THAT PEOPLE WANT TO GET. NEW
JOB SKILLS AND THAT OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM IS A
GREAT THING FOR THAT SO OUR
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAM PACKAGE
AND THE STATUTES THAT WE'RE
GONNA TAKE UP TODAY WILL DO
THIS. ALLOWS MUCH BETTER
FINANCIAL AID FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE GOING TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
INDEPENDENT OF WHAT AGE AND
WHEN THEY WENT TO HIGH SCHOOL.
AND OF COURSE THE DIGITAL
DIVIDE WE HAVE OUR TRAILER BILL
THAT DEALS WITH BROADBAND
INVESTMENTS. VERY SIGNIFICANT
ONES AND OF COURSE OUR
EXPANSION OF CHILD CARE MANY
MORE CHILDREN WILL BE ABLE TO
GET. ACCESS TO MORE AFFORDABLE
CHILDCARE AND THE PEOPLE THAT
ARE PROVIDING THAT CHILD CARE
WILL GET THEIR RATES INCREASED
SO THOSE ARE JUST SOME OF THE
HIGHLIGHTS OF THE TRAILER BILLS
THAT WERE TAKING UP TODAY. SO
WE WILL HEAR THE- TEN TRAILER
BILLS AND THE BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR AND THEN WE WILL HAVE AN
HOUR OF PUBLIC COMMENT AND
AFTER THAT. WE WILL VOTE ON THE
BILLS AND BEFORE I ASK THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
PRESENT. THE BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR. ON MR VICE CHAIR WOULD
YOU LIKE TO COMMENT. SENATOR
FIELDER IN THE LADIES GENTLEMEN
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE. I RISE
TODAY PROBABLY SUPPORTING MORE
TRAILER BILLS THAN I EVER HAVE.
IN PART IT IS A PRODUCT OF YES
IT IS A TRANSITION BUDGET BUT
IT'S A TRANSITION FROM A NUMBER
OF VERY DIFFICULT AND VERY
CHALLENGING YEARS. AND I WON'T
BELABOR MY REMARKS ABOUT
LOOKING OUT FOR THE FUTURE BUT
TO SAY WE HAVE TO BE CAUTIOUS.
BECAUSE THERE WILL BE SOME
SETBACKS THAT AWAIT US SOME OF
A BUILDING ON THE EXPENDITURES
THAT WE HAVE INCREASED HERE.
BUT WITH THAT SAID. I THINK THE
THIRD FOR THE MOST PART THIS
BUDGET IS THOUGH IT'S VERY
VERY. LARGE A LOT OF
EXPENDITURES. I DO BELIEVE THAT
THERE BOOKMAN MANY GOOD
ELEMENTS OF IT WERE THE OF
SUPPORT THAT'S WHAT I'M GOING
TO BE ON THESE KIND OF BILLS
AND I DON'T INTEND TO DEBATE A
LOT TONIGHT SO I WILL NOT KEEP
YOU HERE. REALLY LATE BECAUSE
OF ME. BUT SOMETIMES I WILL GET
UP AND SAY A FEW WORDS BUT
ANYWAY MADAM CHAIR I APPRECIATE
YOUR INDULGENCE. THAN STORING
US THROUGH THE PROCESS. AND
WILL. GET BEGIN TO. TERMINATE
THE BUDGET HERE TODAY. WITH
THESE TRAILER BILLS THOUGH I
KNOW THERE'LL BE MANY MORE TO
COME. THANK YOU SENATOR NELSON
AND OF COURSE YOU AND EVERYONE
IS ON THE COMMITTEE IS WELCOME
TO RAISE COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
ON EACH BILL AS WE GO THROUGH
IT SO LET'S START NOW. WITH AB
ONE SIXTY FOUR THE BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR AND MISLEAD FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO PRESENT. I THINK YEAH-
GOOD AFTERNOON SURE SKINNER
MEISTER NELSON AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE ERIC LEE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- IT
BEFORE I REMARK ON THE- AB ONE
SIXTY FOUR I JUST WANTED TO SAY
THAT I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT ON
THE- ELEVEN BILLS- INCLUDED IN
TODAY'S HEARING. THE GOVERNOR
SIGNED A- SP ONE TWENTY NINE AM
MONDAY WHICH PROVIDES THE
OVERALL ARCHITECTURE FOR THE
BUDGET AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE
LEGISLATURE. AND THE GOVERNOR
AND REFLECTS CALIFORNIA SHARED
PRIORITIES AND OUR SHARED
VALUES- THE FINAL BUDGET AS
THE- CARE SKINNER YOU'VE
MENTIONED IT HAS. INVESTMENTS
IN CHILDCARE IN TRANSITIONAL
KINDERGARTEN HIGHER EDUCATION
IF THIS TOLD HER ACCESS AND
AFFORDABILITY. INCREASES IN
SERVICES FOR. BUT THE- TO-
INVEST IN MAJOR SEARCH SIX.
TELL HOWARD FAMILIES BACK IN
THEIR- AS A- AGING. AMONG MANY
IMPORTANT INVESTMENT- THE
BUDGET ALL RIGHT A LARGE
RECOVERY. IN THE- I'M AS- THAT
YOU'RE STATED THEY ARE STILL-
SOME THINGS NEED TO BE OUT OF
THE SUMMER INCLUDING OUR
CLIMATE. PACK BUT I'M PLEASED.
TO PRESENT ON THESE BILLS. THE
BATTLE BEGAN WITH THE- AB ONE
SIXTY FOUR AMENDS TWENTY ONE
ACT. THIS BILL MAKES TECHNICAL
AND CLARIFYING CHANGES TO
VARIOUS ITEMS IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT
INCLUDING. PROVIDES AN EXTENDED
ENCUMBRANCE PERIOD FOR ONE TIME
FUNDS APPROPRIATED FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA'S
STUDENT ACADEMIC PREPARATION
AND EDUCATIONAL PARTNERSHIP
PROGRAMS. IT SURPRISED THAT
REGIONAL CASE SIX KEEP.
YOUR
SIXTEEN EDUCATION
COLLABORATIVES ARE ELIGE. THE
CANNABIS CONTROL THE WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS- EIGHTY ONE SIXTY
FOUR ALSO REFLECT THE FINAL
BROADBAND PACKAGE AS WAS
MENTIONED. OFFER WHICH I WILL
SPEAK MORE DETAIL IN DETAIL-
LEADER DURING THE EIGHTY ONE
FIFTY SIX PRESENTATION. THANK
YOU- I AM JOINED BY MY
COLLEAGUES AND WE'RE HAPPY TO
RESPOND TO ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE- THANK YOU MISLI
IN A PRETTY. SHADE I HADN'T-
POINTED OUT I THAT YOU OUT THE
IN THIS. BUDGET BILL JUNIOR GOT
FIVE AND DOLLARS. FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL TO. A
NON PAYMASTER FOR NON ARE OR-
AND ADJUSTING THE NEW AND
ADDING TO THE NONPROFIT
PERFORMING ARTS GRANTS PROGRAM.
SO I THINK THIS IS- AS WE KNOW.
OUR ARTS PROGRAMS REALLY
SUFFERED DURING THE PANDEMIC SO
THIS IS REALLY. A VERY GOOD
INVESTMENT LET ME SEE IF
THERE'S ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS THAT ANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES WANT TO MAKE ON THIS
BUDGET BILL JUNIOR. AB ONE
SIXTY FOUR SENATOR NELSON- MY
ONLY CONCERN HERE IS AND I
WON'T REPEAT THIS DEBATE ON
OTHER BILLS BUT WE'RE DOING AN
AWFUL LOT OF SOLE SOURCE. AND
THEY ARE BUDGETING NOW AND I
THINK THAT'S GOING TO BE AN
INCREASING PROBLEM FOR US I
WOULD LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
MONIES FOR THE ARTS COUNCIL OR
FOR ARTS IN CALIFORNIA. FOR
MANY YEARS OUR BUDGET WAS ONLY
A MILLION DOLLARS. FOR THE ARTS
COUNCIL. AND THE K. HAD TO GO
OUT AND- FIX FUNDS SUCH AS A
LICENSE PLATE. BONDING TO DO
WHATEVER ELSE THEY COULD DO TO
IMPROVE. AND MAINTAIN THE ARTS
IN CALIFORNIA. I'M VERY PLEASED
TO SEE IN THIS BUDGET THAT
THEIR RESOURCES ARE GOING TO
GREATLY INCREASE. I BELIEVE
THAT THAT'S GOOD FOR
CALIFORNIA. BECAUSE I BELIEVE
THAT ART IS GOOD FOR
CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU SENATOR
NELSON I HAVE A VERY CLEAR
MEMORY OF A SERVING ON A
CONFERENCE COMMITTEE WITH YOU
WHEN YOU'RE WHEN I THINK THE-
THE AMOUNT OF THE ARTS.
COMMISSION WAS A AGAIN A
COUNCIL WAS ONLY TO BE A MALE
AND IWE MAY TO DOUBLE A TO
TWO. AND- IT WAS IN PARTLY ON
YOUR- URGING SO. AGAIN LET'S
ANY OF COMMENTS OR. HIS LEAVE
FROM DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO
PRESENT. THANK YOU YES ACTUALLY
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
ON EIGHTY ONE THIRTY ONE THE
CHILD DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS-
THIS PROVIDES PROVISIONS
RELATED TO CHILD CARE PROVIDER
RATES CHILD CARE SLOTS THE
CHILD CARE PANDEMIC RELIEF
PACKAGE FUNDED BY FEDERAL
FUNDS. AND INFRASTRUCTURE
GRANTS FOR CHILD CARE
FACILITIES SOME OF WHICH WERE
INCLUDED IN THE APRIL OR JUNE
CHILDCARE PROVIDERS UNITED
AGREEMENTS WITH THE STATE. MORE
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL INCLUDES
INCREASES TO THE REGIONAL
MARKET RATE FOR R. M. R. WHICH
WILL BE RAISED FROM THE SEVENTY
FIFTH PERCENTILE THE TWENTY
SIXTEEN. RMR SURVEY TO THE
SEVENTY FIFTH PERCENTILE OF THE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN OUR OUR AND OUR
SURVEY AFFECTED JANUARY OF NEXT
YEAR- IT ALSO INCREASES- HAS
INCREASES TO THE STANDARD
REIMBURSEMENT RATE PER PER FOR
PROVIDERS INCLUDING FOR CHILD
CARE AND PRESCHOOL PROVIDERS.
WHO WILL RECEIVE A FOUR POINT
005% COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT-
AS OF JULY OF THIS YEAR. AND
THE BILLING CLUES- ALL. EXEMPT
BY RECEIVING SUB TO SEE PER OF
THE LIFE FAMILY CHILD CARE
RIGHT. CEILING EFFECTIVE JAN.
OF NEXT YEAR. OTHER BILL
EXPANDS CARE ACCESS BY ADDING
OVER A HIGH FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
NEW CHILD SLOTS FIGHTS TWO
TWENTY THREE. AND BIRTH OF
TWENTY THOUSAND NEW SLOTS
ANNUALLY THROUGH TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY SIX- SHOULD THE STATE'S
ECONOMIC CONDITIONS SUPPORTED.
THE BILL ALLOCATES FIVE HUNDRED
SEVENTY NINE MILLION OF FEDERAL
FUNDS TO CHILD CARE AND
PRESCHOOL PROVIDERS. PURSUANT
TO THE APRIL CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS UNITED AGREEMENT-
FURTHER THE BILL PROVIDES GREAT
SUPPLEMENTS IT IS THAT WHICH IS
A JOINT TRAINING AND EDUCATION
PARTNERSHIP FUND TO ADDRESS THE
RELATED WORKFORCE NEEDS OF ALL
FAMILY CHILD CARE PROVIDERS-
AND INCENTIVES TO RETAIN THE
LICENSED PROVIDERS. AND LASTLY
THE BILL INCLUDES THE ATHORITY
TO IMPLEMENT INFRASTRUCTURE
GRANTS OF TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION FOR THE ACQUISITION
CONSTRUCTION. DEVELOPMENT AND A
RENOVATION OF THE CHILD CARE
FACILITIES. AGAIN I'M JOINED BY
MY COLLEAGUES AND WE'RE HAPPY
TO RESPOND TO ANY COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS. GREAT BUT SEE IF
THERE ARE ANY. SENATOR NELSON
BRIEFLY LADIES AND GENTLEMAN
THE BILL DOES. INCREASED STAFF
AND VERY SIGNIFICANTLY P. WIVES
AS THEY ARE CALLED THE LEGEND
LISTED BROUGHT INDEED TO OUR
ATTENTION. THE GREATEST CONCERN
I HAVE WITH THIS OVERALL THOUGH
SECTION OF THE BUDGET. IT
APPEARS TO ME THAT WHAT THEY
NOW CALL THE IN THIS LANGUAGE
THE CHILD CARE UNION. IN THERE
MAYBE COME CHILDCARE UNIONS
PEARL SOMETIME. BUT IT ACCORDS
IN A LOT OF. CONCESSIONS
ALREADY THAT I THINK SHOULD BE
SUBJECT TO COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING. THAT BEING THE CASE
JUST BE AWARE THAT THAT IS A
CONCERN THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
I WOULD- SHE COMMENTED I AM IN
ADDITION BEING THE BUDGETARY
ALSO IN THE- VICE CHAIR OF THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS AND THIS IS A
THIS WAS A PRIORITY FOR THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS TO. INCREASE
THE- AMOUNT OF CHILDCARE- THE
CALL SLOTS AVAILABLE TO OUR
FAMILIES WHO CAN'T AFFORD IT
OTHERWISE AND ALSO TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR PROVIDERS ARE PAID.
BETTER AND- THIS BUDGET DOES
THIS THIS BILL ENACTS THOSE
THINGS AND I THINK THAT WE ARE
VERY VERY HAPPY TO SEE THIS
PROGRESS. SO WITH THAT WE'LL GO
ON TO AB ONE THIRTY TWO THE
HIGHER ED BILL. AND DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE I ALLOW YOU TO
DESCRIBE WHAT'S IN THAT. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR ACTUALLY WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
EIGHTY ONE THIRTY TWO- HIGHER
EDUCATION TRAILER BILL. THIS
BILL AMONG OTHER PROVISIONS
IMPLEMENT SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENTS IN STUDENT
FINANCIAL AID AND COLLEGE
AFFORDABILITY INCLUDING AN
EXPANSION OF THE CALIFORNIA
KIDS INVESTMENT AND DEVELOPMENT
SAVINGS PROGRAM ALSO KNOWN AS-CAL KIDS- A COLLEGE SAVINGS
ACCOUNT PROGRAM IT PROVIDES A
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR. DEPOSITS
FOR PUBLIC SCHOOL STUDENTS FROM
LOW INCOME FAMILIES ENGLISH
LEARNERS AND FOSTER YOUTH WITH
SUPPLEMENTAL DEPOSITS FOR
FOSTER YOUTH AND HOMELESS
CHILDREN- AN EXTENSION OF THE
CAL GRANT ENTITLEMENT PROGRAM
FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
IS ALSO INCLUDED- THERE IS A-
ALSO THE REVISION OF THE MIDDLE
CLASS SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM TO
PROVIDE ELIGIBLE STUDENTS WITH
SCHOLARSHIPS INTENDED TO COVER
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE
TOTAL COST OF ATTENDANCE. AND
OTHER SOURCES OF AID. THE BILL
ALSO ESTABLISHES A LEARNING
ALIGNED EMPLOYMENT PROGRAM AT
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY AND
CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITY COLLEGES
TO HELP UNDERREPRESENTED
STUDENTS WITH FINANCIAL NEED
GAIN RELEVANT WORK EXPERIENCE-
THIS BILL ALSO IMPLEMENTS
IMPROVEMENTS TO COLLEGE ACCESS
SUCH AS ESTABLISHING A DUAL
ADMISSIONS PROGRAM THAT
ESTABLISHES- ELIGIBLE THAT
PROVIDES ELIGIBLE IRST TIME
FRESHMAN. APPLICANTS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR GUARANTEED
ADMISSION TO UC OR CSU CAMPUS
OF THEIR CHOICE FOLLOWING
COMPLETION OF AN ASSOCIATE
DEGREE FOR TRANSFER OR ANOTHER
TRANSFER PATHWAY AT A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE- AND FINALLY- EIGHTY
ONE THIRTY TWO INCLUDES
PROVISIONS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SUCH AS
RETIRING THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
APPORTIONMENT DEFERRALS- AGAIN
WE'RE HAPPY TO RESPOND TO ANY
QUESTIONS. GREAT CENTER LAYER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I JUST
THE THOUGHT OF PARTICULARLY I
KNOW SENATOR SO TROUBLED AND
MEN AND I ALL WORKED IN THE
EDUCATION BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
BUT IT'S JUST REALLY
APPROPRIATE TO NOT LET THIS
PASS WITHOUT NOTING THAT THIS
IS THE BEST BUDGET FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION IN CALIFORNIA IN
MODERN TIMES THE ARCHITECTURE
OF THE BUDGET WHICH AS THEBAR
REPRESENTATIVE OF FINANCE SAID
WAS ALREADY SIGNED. UP R. AS
THE BACKDROP REALLY EDIT CAME
IN THREE SLUGS THIS YEAR
BECAUSE THE GOVERNOR IN THE JAN
TEN BUDGET- DIDN'T BRING US
BACK TO THE AREA TO THE LEVEL
THAT HIGHER EDUCATION WAS PRIOR
TO THE PANDEMIC THE STIMULUS
DID THAT OR LATER IN THE YEAR
AND THEN THE BUDGET THAT WE
HAVE ADOPTED BRINGS US BACK TO
WHERE WE WERE BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC PLUS A ROUGHLY 5% COST
OF LIVING INCREASE FOR CSU UC
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AND
SIGNIFICANT AMONG IT IS WHAT
WAS MENTIONED THAT THIS IS THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT REFORM OF
STUDENT AID IN MODERN TIMES
WHETHER IT'S CAL GRANT THE
MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP ARE WE
REALLY WILL ADD A HUNDRED
THOUSAND STUDENTS OVER THE
SHORT TERM TO FINANCIAL
ASSISTANCE AND IT IT IS IN THIS
TRAILER BILL AND IT REALLY
TAKES THINGS BEFORE IT WAS A
LIMITED AMOUNT OF MONEY AND ALL
THE RULES FOR JUST TO SCREEN
PEOPLE OUT. AND NOW THERE WILL
BE NO PENALTY FOR BEING A
REENTRY STUDENTS THERE WILL BE
NO PENALTY FOR HOW YOU FINISHED
IN YOUR GRADE POINT AVERAGE
BEFORE FEW OF FINANCIAL NEED
AND YOU'RE QUALIFIED AND YOU'RE
ADMITTED THIS WILL REALLY HELP
YOU ALONG AND IT REALLY DOES
MOVE US TOWARD THE GOAL OF A
DEBT FREE COLLEGE EXPERIENCE.
NOT A FREE COLLEGE EXPERIENCE
DEBT FREE CAR X. AND THEN
ADDITIONALLY. THE REFORM THAT
REALLY DEALS WITH OUT OF STATE
STUDENTS AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IS INCLUDED HERE
WELL AND I THINK IT WAS A
COMPROMISE COMPARED TO WHERE IT
STARTED BECAUSE WHERE IT
STARTED IT WAS SORT OF LET'S
LIMIT TO A FLAT AMOUNT OF OUT
OF STATE STUDENTS AT EACH OF
THE TEN CAMPUSES AND WORD
GODDESS THE THREE CAMPUSES.
THAT HAVE THE HIGHEST
PERCENTAGE OF OUT OF STATE
STUDENTS WILL IN ESSENCE- BE
LIMITED AND WE WILL FIND THE
LOSS OF MONEY FROM THAT CHANGE
FROM OUT OF STATE IN STATE AND
BECAUSE WE FUNDED YOU SEE
ADDITIONAL ENROLLMENT TO THE
NEIGHBORHOOD OF SIXTY FIVE
HUNDRED SLOTS IT WILL B A
SOFTER LANDING FOR UC IN
IMPLEMENTING THAT REFORM OF OUT
OF STATE STUDENTS WE ALSO PAID
OFF THE DEFERRALS AT COMMUNITY
COLLEGES SO IN KEEPING WITH ALL
ACROSS EDUCATION. WE ARE PAYING
OFF DEBT AND GETTING OUT OF THE
DEFERRALS SO THAT WE CAN BACK
ME BACK STANDING ON OUR FEET
AND- THERE ARE MANY OTHER
THINGS STUDENT ACCESS TRAINING
AND THE IMPORTANT THING IS
THERE THIRTY NINE ITEMS IN THIS
TRAILER BILL AND IT'S JUST A
REAL TRIBUTE TO THE DIFFERENT
PROBLEMS WE ARE ADDRESSING SO I
THINK WE SHOULD ALL BE PROUD TO
VOTE FOR THIS BILL. OUR WAITER
TODAY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK ON. AND
THANK YOU SENATOR LAYERED FOR
CHEERING THAT SUBCOMMITTEE IN
OVERSEEING THIS GOOD WORK AND
FOR YOUR COLLEAGUES WHO SERVED
ON IT. AND THE AS YOU DESCRIBED
THESE ARE SIGNIFICANT
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS THEY'RE
GOING TO BENEFIT. ALL OF
CALIFORNIA AND REALLY IMPROVE
THE ABILITY FOR CALIFORNIANS TO
EITHER GO TO COLLEGE FOR THE
FIRST TIME OR GO BACK TO
COLLEGE WHICHEVER IT IS THAT
THEY ARE SEEKING. AND SENATOR
NIELSEN GO AHEAD. MADAM
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES I WANT
TO PARTICULARLY PRAISED THE
WORK OF THIS SUBCOMMITTEE. I
REMEMBER THE BIGGEST BOOST EVER
FOR HIGHER ED WAS BACK IN I
THINK EIGHTY TWO WITH DEFLATION
KP 30% INCREASE A SURPRISE IN
THE THAT'S A CONSERVATIVE
GOVERNOR. BUT OVER THE YEARS
HAS BEEN A STRUGGLE. AND A MORE
RECENT TIMES A HECK OF A
STRUGGLE JUST THAT THE STRUGGLE
AND NOW THIS IS A GREAT ADVANCE
IN A LEAP FORWARD FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION REFORMS AT THE CHAIR
JUST OUTLINED ARE VERY
SIGNIFICANT. AND I BELIEVE THAT
THE THIS IS WITH AN EMPTY I
LIKE ABOUT IT IS THE OUT OF
STATE- PARTICULARLY OUT OF
COUNTRY. STUDENTS OF LIMITING
THAT SOME TO THE ADVANTAGE OF
CALIFORNIA. BORN AND RAISED
STUDENTS THAT IS A SIGNIFICANT
REFORM FILL MY COMPLIMENTS TO
SOMEONE. GREAT TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER. MEMBERS WHO
WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT ON THE
HIGHER ED TRAILER BILL. ALL
RIGHT SEEING NONE WE WILL MOVE
ON TO A. B. ONE THIRTY THREE
THE HEALTH TRAILER BILL GO HEAD
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU ACTUALLY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON EIGHTY
ONE THIRTY THREE THE HEALTH
TRAILER BILL. SINCE LAST
PRESENTED TO THIS COMMITTEE
EIGHTY ONE THIRTY THREE HAS
UNDERGONE SOME AMENDMENTS
INCLUDING ESTABLISHING AN
INNOVATIVE AND PREVENTION FOCUS
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SYSTEM WHERE
ALL CHILDREN YOUTH TWENTY FIVE
YEARS OF AGE OR YOUNGER ARE
ROUTINELY ROUTINELY SCREENED
SUPPORTED AND SERVED FOR
EMERGING AND EXISTING.
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS
REGARDLESS OF PAIR. OF
EXPANDING THE COMMUNITY
CONTINUUM OF BEHAVIOR HEALTH
TREATMENT RESOURCES BY
PROVIDING GRANTS TO QUALIFIED
ENTITIES TO CONSTRUCT A CHOIR
AND REHABILITATE REAL ESTATE
ASSETS OR TO INVEST IN MOBILE
CRISIS INFRASTRUCTURE. OUT
REMOVING EIGHTY NINETY SEVEN
MEDICARE MEDI CAL RATE FREEZE
ON INTERMEDIATE CARE FACILITIES
FOR THE DEVELOPMENTALLY
DISABLED AND FREESTANDING
PEDIATRIC SUB ACUTE FACILITIES-
THIS BILL ESTABLISHES THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES DATA EXCHANGE
FRAMEWORK TO FACILITATE THE
SHARING OF HEALTH INFORMATION
ACROSS PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
ENTITIES. AND STANDARDIZES
POLICIES PROCEDURES WITH THE
GOAL OF IMPROVING HEALTHCARE
OUTCOMES- THIS BILL CONVENES A
WORK GROUP LED BY THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY TO IDENTIFY
SHORT MEDIUM AND LONG TERM
DELIVERABLES TO RESOLVE THE
INCOMPETENT TO STAND OR I. S.
T. SORRY INCOMPETENT TO STAND
TRIAL OR I. S. D. CRISIS BY
NOVEMBER THIRTIETH OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE- I DID CONTINUE TO
ADDRESS THE EYES TO ISSUE THIS
BILL ALSO AUTHORIZES THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
TO CONTRACTORS OF THE KEYPAD
CAPACITY TO ADDRESS THE
INCREASING NUMBER. OF I. S. T.
PATIENT REFERRALS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS.
AND FINALLY THIS BILL INCLUDES
THIRTEEN MILLION I'M GOING
GENERAL FUND TO SUPPORT
INVESTMENTS TO END THE
EPIDEMICS OF HIV AIDS HEPATITIS
C. AND SEXUALLY TRANSMITTED
INFECTIONS. WITH THAT I'M HAPPY
TO RESPOND TO QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. THANK YOU ANYONE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
ABOUT AB ONE THIRTY THREE THE
HEALTH TRAILER BILL. HI YES
SENATOR PAN I THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR A CENTERS I JUST- WANTED
TO JUST BRIEFLY COMMENT. ON ALL
THE SINGING WELL LET'S JUST SAY
THERE ARE SO MANY SIGNIFICANT
THINGS IN THIS HEALTH TAYLOR
BELL AND THEN I WOULD ALSO HAVE
TO MAKE NOTE THAT- WE'RE NOT
QUITE DONEWITH HEALTH YET
EITHER SO- LIKE KNOWLEDGE THAT-
WE'RE STILL WORKING ON SOME
ADDITIONAL THINGS WITH
ADMINISTRATION- REGARDING THE
HEALTH ISSUE US. AS WELL BUT-
CERTAINLY IS A PEDIATRICIAN
AND- AND- AS WELL AS THE CHAIR
OF THE HOUSE COMMITTEE I MEAN
THERE THERE WHAT WE'RE GONNA
TRY TO DO TO ADDRESS-
CHILDREN'S MENTAL HEALTH WHAT
WE'RE DOING TO- REFORM THE COW
IT YOU KNOW THE MEDICAL SYSTEM
THROUGH CALLING HIM TO CUTTING
CORPORATE MORE SOCIAL TERMS AS
HEALTH- AND MANY OTHER REALLY
IMPORTANT- ISSUES ARE ARE- ARE
IN THIS- I WOULD MAKE NOTES
BECAUSE- I KNOW ARCHER IS
TALKED ABOUT THE
TRANSFORMATIONAL NATURE OF THIS
BUDGET. IS THAT- WE ALSO I ALSO
IN THE ARCTIC KNOWLEDGE THAT
EVEN WITH THE PASSAGE-
HOPEFULLY PASSAGE OF THIS
BUDGET TRAILER BILL- THAT'S
BASICALLY THE BEGINNING AND
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK FOR US TO
CONTINUE TO DO BECAUSE THERE
ARE BOLD PROGRAMS ARE BEING
PROPOSED AND ALL OF US KNOW
THAT- THEY ALL THAT- THOSE ARE
GREAT IDEAS AND THEN WE GOT
FIGURE OUT HOW TO TAKE THOSE
IDEAS TO FRUITION SO THERE'S
GOING TO BE ON GOING WORK. BUT
THE OPPORTUNITY. TO ACTUALLY.
START THOSE BIG IDEAS PUT THE
RESOURCES BEHIND THIS THAT IS
THE PART THAT WE SHOULD
CELEBRATE- TODAY. AS WE MOVE
THIS BUDGET FORD
INSTRUMENTALITY KNOWLEDGE THAT
IN THE IN RECOGNIZING WHAT'S IN
THIS HEALTH TRAILER BILLS WELL.
AND HOPEFULLY ALSO. I MEAN
THAT'S THAT'S OUR DESCRIBED THE
WHOLE BUDGET AS WELL BUT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU DR PAN THANKS
VERY MUCH SENATOR PAN- ALL
RIGHT. SEEING NO OTHER COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS WE WILL GO TO
EIGHTY ONE THIRTY FIVE. THE
HUMAN SERVICES TRAILER BILL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR ERICA LEE
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
EIGHTY ONE THIRTY FIVE THE
HUMAN SERVICES TRAILER ABOUT%
THIS BILL AS PART OF THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET PACKAGE.
MAKES STATUTORY CHANGES TO
IMPLEMENT THE BUDGET ACT
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL INCLUDES
PROVISIONS PERTAINING TO
HOUSING AND HOMELESSNESS
PROGRAMS. THAT ARE ADMINISTERED
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES INCLUDING HOME SAFE
FOR WHICH NINETY TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION IS PROVIDED IN THE
BUDGET IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AND TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE FOR
ACCESS TO HEALTH SAFETY. AND
HOUSING SUPPORTS FOR
INDIVIDUALS INVOLVED IN OR AT
RISK OF INVOLVEMENT IN ADULT
PROTECTIVE SERVICES. AS WELL AS
THE HOUSING AND DISABILITY
ADVOCACY PROGRAM FOR WHICH ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION IS
PROVIDED IN THE BUDGET IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO. AND
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE TO
INCREASE PARTICIPATION
PARTICIPATION AMONG HOMELESS
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES. YOU
MAY BE ELIGIBLE FOR DISABILITY
BENEFITS. EIGHTY ONE THIRTY
FIVE INCLUDES PROVISIONS
PERTAINING TO THE SUPPLEMENTAL
SECURITY INCOME OR STATE
SUPPORT MENTAL PAYMENT ALSO
KNOWN AS SS I SS P. PROGRAM.
INTO THE IN HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES ARE I. HSS PROGRAM
INCLUDING AN ACCESS P. GRANT
INCREASE FOR WHICH TWO HUNDRED
NINETY ONE POINT TREE MILLION
I'M GOING IT'S INCLUDED IN THE
BUDGET TO INCREASE GRANTS. FOR
S. S. P. CASH ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM FOR IMMIGRANTS ARE
KATHY AND CALIFORNIA VETERANS
CASH BENEFITS- ALSO INCLUDED A
STATE AND COUNTY SHARING. STATE
AND COUNTY SHARING RATIO
CHANGES THE BUDGET INCLUDES
INCREASE STATE COSTS A FIFTY
SEVEN POINT THREE MILLION IN
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND
HUNDRED TWENTY THREE POINT
EIGHT MILLION I'M GOING. TO
REFLECT THE CONTINUATION OF THE
65% STATE AND 35% COUNTY
SHARING RATIO. AS WELL THE
CONTINUATION OF THE 10% OVER
THREE YEARS OPTION FOR THE IHS
US PROGRAM- ADDITIONALLY FOR
ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES THE
BUDGET INCLUDES SEVENTY
MILLION. GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO AND I'M GOING
FOR ADULT PROTECTIVE SERVICES
EXPANSION. I'M AT ONE THIRTY
FIVE INCLUDES PROVISIONS
PERTAINING TO THE CALYX PROGRAM
INCLUDING AT CAL EXPRESS RECESS
THE BUDGET REFLECTS A FIVE
POINT 3% INCREASE TO CA WORKS
MAXIMUM AID. PAYMENT LEVELS-
THE FEDERAL PANDEMIC EMERGENCY
ASSISTANCE FUND THE BUDGET
INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED FOUR
MILLION FEDERAL PANDEMIC
EMERGENCY ASSISTANCE FUND TEN
F. TO PROVIDE ONE TIME CASH
PAYMENT. TO CAL WORKS FAMILIES.
EIGHTY ONE THIRTY FIVE INCLUDES
PROVISIONS PERTAINING TO
CALFRESH AND FOOD PROGRAMS
INCLUDING CALIFORNIA FOOD
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM EXPANSIONS
THIS IS SPEECH. ON THE BUDGET
INCLUDES FIVE MILLION IN TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO TWO EXPANSIVE
OUT TO INDIVIDUALS REGARDLESS
OF IMMIGRATION STATUS. OF FOOD
BANK RESOURCES THE BUDGET
INCLUDES ONE HUNDRED TEN
MILLION- FOR FOODBANK
RESOURCES. FOOD BANK A PAST
CITY AND CLIMATE RESILIENCE-
THE BUDGET INCLUDES A HUNDRED
EIGHTY TWO MILLION FOR FOOD
BANK ABOUT THE ENHANCEMENT
CLIMATE RESILIENCE- AND
CALFRESH ADMINISTRATION COSTS
FOR STUDENT EXPANSION THE
BUDGET INCLUDES ELEVEN POINT
NINE MILLION. THE COUNTY
ADMINISTRATION RELATED TO THE
CALFRESH TEMPORARY ELIGIBILITY
EXPANSION FOR COLLEGE STUDENTS-
THE BUDGET ALSO INCLUDES THIRTY
MILLION ONE TIME FOR A DIAPER
BANKS TO MAKE OF IT NINETEEN-
PANDEMIC DEMANDS. THE ALSO. THE
CALIFORNIA RICH PAYMENT PROGRAM
UTILIZING ONE BILLION DOLLARS
FROM FEDERAL OUR FUNDS. THE
BILL PRIORITIZES THE
DISTRIBUTION OF CHILD SUPPORT
COLLECTIONS TO FAMILIES OVER
GOVERNMENT RECRUITMENTAND
FINALLY THE BILL ALLOWS THE
DEPARTMENT. OF CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES TO SEASON FOUR SPENT A
CHILD SUPPORT ARREARS AGES THAT
ARE OWED TO THE STATE THAT HAVE
BEEN DETERMINED TO BE.
UNCOLLECTIBLE THOSE ARE SOME OF
THE MAJOR PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL AND WE'RE HAPPY TO RESPOND
TO ANY QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE
MIGHT HAVE. THANK YOU LET'S SEE
IF THERE ARE. FROM SENATOR PAN
I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND- I
DID IT DO SOMETHING IS- WAS
PRESENTED BY- MISLEAD US A LOT
OF EXCELLENT THINGS I JUST WANT
TO TAKE WE RECOGNIZE AND
APPRECIATE- THE WORK ON THE IHS
US PROGRAM- REPEALING THE 7%
REDUCTION THAT'S SOMETHING I'VE
BEEN WORKING ON FOR YEARS- AND
AGAIN TIS IS PROGRAMS
ESSENTIAL FOR HELPING- SO
SUPPORTING OUR SENIORS PEOPLE
DISABILITIES. ALSO ACTUALLY
MAINTAINING THE STATE COUNTY
COST RATIO BECAUSE WHAT PEOPLE
MAY NOT REALIZE IS THAT BECAUSE
OF THE REALIGNMENT. ESSENTIALLY
IF THAT WASN'T RIVER IF WE
DIDN'T. MAINTAIN THAT INSTEAD
REVERSED IT WAS PLANNED THAT
WOULD PUT A SQUEEZE ON BOTH
MENTAL HEALTH AND PUBLIC HEALTH
IS WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF
PANDEMIC IN TERMS OF LOCAL
FUNDING SO THIS WAS REALLY
IMPORTANT. AS AS WELL WHILE
STILL ENSURING THAT WE ARE
VITAL SERVICES FOR OUR SENIORS.
I HAVE TO I JUST SAYS SO I JUST
WANNA RECOGNIZE THAT PARTICULAR
I KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF OTHER
EXCELLENT THINGS AS WELL BUT-
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND-
CENTER PAN I WAS KIND OF RAISED
THE SAME THING I'M REALLY GLAD
YOU BROUGHT UP. THE CHANGES
THAT THIS TRAILER BILL DOES FOR
IN HOME. SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
PROGRAM REPEALING THAT 7%
REDUCTION IN THE SERVICE HOURS
WHAT WE SAW DURING THE PANDEMIC
AND OF COURSE THIS THIS-
REDUCTION IS BEEN FOR A LONG
TIME BUT- DURING THE PANDEMIC.
WE SAW MANY PEOPLE WERE EACH
DAY SOME PEOPLE LOST THEIR JOBS
BUT SOME PEOPLE WERE UNABLE TO
GO TO WORK BECAUSE SO MANY OF
THE SERVICES THAT THEY RELIED
ON TO TAKE CARE OF FAMILY
MEMBERS. HAD TO BE SUSPENDED OR
WERE NOT BEING ABLE TO BEAT YOU
KNOW COULDN'T BE- DEPLOYED. AND
SO THEN THEY HAD TO STAY HOME
AND TAKE CARE OF THOSE FAMILY
MEMBERS NOW THAT OF COURSE. IF
WE DON'T. PUT THOSE SERVICES
BACK THEN PEOPLE HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO STAY HOME THAT
HURTS THE ECONOMY IT ONLY HURTS
THE FAMILY WHO'S YOU KNOW
DOESN'T HAVE THAT INCOME IT
ALSO HURTS THE ECONOMY BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE PEOPLE GETTING
BACK TO WORK. SO PART OF MY
CELEBRATION OF THE CHILDCARE.
AND SOME OF THE EDUCATION
THINGS WE DID LIKE T. K. IN.
THE AFTER SCHOOL AND THEN OF
COURSE THIS I. HSS IS BECAUSE
IT TAKES THAT BURDEN. OFF
FAMILY MEMBERS TO ALLOW FOR ONE
TO NEED CARE TO GET THE CARE
THEY NEED TO REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT YOU POINTED OUT AND THEN I
WOULD POINT OUT THAT IN TERMS
OF THE RESPONSIBLE BUDGETING
SIDE. THE HISTORY WOULD BILL
ALSO TRANSFERS. THE FUNDS FROM
THE GENERAL FUND THAT WE HAVE
COMMITTED TO BOOSTING UP OUR
SAFETY NET RESERVE SO AT THAT
POINT WHEN WE HAVE SOME
ECONOMIC PROOF PRESSURES WHICH
WE KNOW INEVITABLY WILL COME.
NOT ONLY HAVE WE INCREASED OUR
OVERALL JUST RAINY DAY FUND BUT
WE'RE ALSO INCREASING OUR
SAFETY NET RESERVE. SENATOR
NIELSEN. MADAM CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES. THE DIFFICULTY I
HAVE WITH THIS PARTICULAR BILL.
IT IS MORE PROVISIONS ONEROUS
PROVISIONS THAT WOULD BE
HELPFUL TO THE UNION. AND
HARMFUL TO OUR COUNTIES THE
COUNTIES ARE GONNA PARTICULARLY
OBJECT TO SOME OF THE FETTERS
PLACED UPON THEM BY THIS AND
LASTLY THE- THIS IS A
CONTINUATION OF A ROLL BACK. OF
THE SIGNIFICANT WELFARE REFORMS.
AFFECTED HERE IN THE EIGHTIES.
A COMBINATION PROBABLY THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT COMBINATION OF
LIBERALS AND CONSERVATIVES EVER
TO REFORM WELFARE. SO
SIGNIFICANT THAT PRESIDENT
CLINTON ADOPTED THAT AS A KEY
ELEMENT IN HIS ACCOUNT OF THE
WELFARE REFORM AND WE ARE
CONTINUING HERE TO ROLL THAT
BACK I THINK THAT'S GOING TO BE
EVENTUALLY THE PROBLEM THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. RIGHT SINGLE
OTHER COMMENTS- WE WILL GO TO.
AB ONE FORTY ON HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS BOURBON FINANCE.
CURRENTLY WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE ON AB ONE FORTY THE
HOUSING TRAILER FELL BY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT INCLUDES
A HISTORICAL BUSINESS PACKAGE
UP CLOSE TO TWELVE BILLION OVER
TWO YEARS THAT MAKES
INVESTMENTS THROUGH A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH OF
HOUSING SERVICES ACROSS A RANGE
OF HOMELESSNESS INTERVENTIONS
TO REBUILD CALIFORNIA'S
BEHAVIOR HEALTH HOUSING SYSTEM-
EXPAND ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ASSIST LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO DEVELOPING
CHAPMAN OUTREACH STRATEGIES AND
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES.
FOR HUNKY ACQUISITIONS THAT
ALSO INCLUDES A TEN BILLION
HOUSING TEN BILLION DOLLAR
HOUSING PACKAGE TO PROMOTE AND
MAINTAIN STABLE HOUSING YOU'RE
ADDITIONALLY EXPANDED RENTAL
ASSISTANCE FOR CLOSURE
PREVENTION MORTGAGE ASSISTANCE
AND FIRST TIME HOME OWNERS.
THIS BILL PROVIDES THE
STATUTORY FRAMEWORK FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF A SIGNIFICANT
PORTION OF THAT- OF THOSE
INVESTMENTS THAT I JUST
MENTIONED. WHAT MOST NOTABLE
AMONG THE HIGH. PROVISIONS OF
THE BUDGET- R. TWO POINT SEVEN
FIVE BILLION TO CONTINUE ON KEY
ACQUISITIONS. TWO BILLION APART
LOCAL FLEXIBLE AID- KNOWN AS
HALF. A BILLION FOR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND
ANOTHER MILLION FOR TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. FIFTY MILLION FOR
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE
ENCAMPMENT RESOLUTION FUNDING
PROGRAM FORTY MILLION FOR THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE FAMILY
HOMELESSNESS CHALLENGE GRANTS.
AND TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM- AND FIVE POINT SIX
MILLION ONE TIME GENERAL
PURPOSE THAT'S THAT STATE
FUNDED HOMELESSNESS PROGRAMS.
SOME NOTABLE HOUSING PROVISIONS
IN THE BUDGET INCLUDED
PERMITTING H. SEATS PROVIDE
LOANS OR GRANTS TO SHOVEL READY
PROJECTS THAT HAVE SUCCESSFULLY
ACQUIRED HCV BINDING. TEXT BUT
I THE CONSTRUCTION OF
PRODUCTION OR PORTABLE HOUSING
IN LIEU OF WAITING FOR STATE
TAX CREDIT AVAILABILITY WHICH
IN SOME CASES CAN TAKE MULTIPLE
YEARS- THE BUDGET INCLUDES ONE
POINT. SEVEN FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS FOR THE CLUB. THAT'S
HOW SHE NEVER. EARLY ACTS
PLANNING GRANTS AND TWENTY. FOR
ABOUT SIX HUNDRED MILLION IN
ONE TIME GRANTS TO REGIONAL
AND- TO FIND SUSTAINABLE
HOUSING GOALS. AND ALSO RESULT
IN REDUCED PER CAPITA VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED. ON THIS BILL
REQUIRES HEDT CARRIAGE OF BAY
AND THE TREASURY TO PROVIDE A
LEGISLATIVE REPORT ON THE
FEASIBILITY AND LOGISTICS OF
ESTABLISHING THE CALIFORNIA
DREAM. PROGRAM A SELF
SUSTAINING STATE FINANCING
PROGRAM. TO LISTEN TO ASSIST
LOW INCOME. HOW BUYERS
PURCHASING A PORTABLE- AND
INVESTING IN PRESERVATION IS
THAT EACH TV TO MAKE LOANS OR
GRANTS TO REHABILITATE OPERATOR
EXTENDED A LONG TERM
AFFORDABILITY OF LEGACY HCV
HOUSING UNITS ABOUT TO BECOME
MARKET RATE- THAT INCLUDES
THREE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
FOR THIS PURPOSE- AND FINALLY I
JUST WANT TO SAY THAT THIS BILL
ALSO ESTABLISHES THE
FORECLOSURE INTERVENTION
HOUSING PRESERVATON PROGRAM
UNDER ECT TO PROVIDE LOANS OR
GRANTS TO COMMUNITY LAND TRUST
AN AFFORDABLE HOUSING NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS. TO ACQUIRE SMALL
MULTI FAMILY HOUSING AT RISK OF
FORECLOSURE IN ORDER TO USE FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THE BUDGET
EXCEEDS FIVE HUNDRED MILLION-
FOR THAT SO I'M HERE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES AND HAPPY. TO
RESPOND TO ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE. ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS ON THIS ONE. WELL I'M
NOT GOING TO LET THIS- DEPARTED
FRIEND AND SHE DID A GREAT JOB
IN ORDER TO LET IT GO BY
WITHOUT- REITERATING HOW
IMPRESSIVE THIS IS. THAT WE ARE
GOING TO BE INVESTING. IN
SERIOUS SERIOUS EFFORT TO
REDUCE HOMELESSNESS IN THIS
STATE WHICH WE KNOW IS THAT
CRISIS LEVELS BY INVESTING
TWELVE BILLION OVER TWO YEARS.
BUT IN ADDITION TO THAT. WE ARE
HELPING TO THE OTHER
INVESTMENTS IN HERE WILL HELP
PREVENT HOMELESSNESS. FOR
EXAMPLE IS THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE POINTED OUT. IT ALLOWS
OUR- TREASURY IN CALIFORNIA
HOUSING FINANCE AGENCY TO PUT
TOGETHER A CALIFORNIA DREAM FOR
ALL FIRST TIME HOME BUYERS
PROGRAM. AND THEN. I HOPE THAT
WE DO NOT FACE THIS BUT IF WE
DO FACE A WAVE OF FORECLOSURES
DUTY ECONOMIC HARM THAT THE
PANDEMIC CAUSED ON SOME
HOUSEHOLDS. THAT WE NOW HAVE
THE ABILITY. TO WITH FINDING
HERE TO SUPPORT COMMUNITY LAND
TRUSTS TO PURCHASE THOSE
FORECLOSED HOMES SO THAT THEY
CAN MAKE THEM AVAILABLE TO LOW
INCOME HOMEOWNERS AND
POTENTIALLY EVEN TO THE VERY
HOMEOWNER WHO'S- WAS FORECLOSED
ON. AND OF MY DISTRICT JUST HAD
THE A LAND TRUST PURCHASED A
FORECLOSED HOME FOR THE TENANT
WHO LIVED IN THAT HOME WHO'S
NOW GOING TO BE THE HOMEOWNER.
AND SO THEY BENEFITED FROM A
CHANGE IN THE LAW THAT WE DID
BY CHANGING THE WAY THAT
FORECLOSED HOMES ARE SOLD AT
AUCTION AND NOW WE'RE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THAT EFFORT
WITH THE STATE FUNDS. SO THIS
IS- I FEEL THIS IS A REALLY
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TRAILER
BILL I'M VERY HAPPY THAT WE ARE
PROCEEDING ON IT. AND LEWIS'S
ANY OTHER COMMENT I WILL MOVE
ON THEN TO AB ONE FORTY SORRY
THIS IS A B. ONE FORTY TO
EIGHTY ONE FORTY FOUR THE FILM
AND TELEVISION TAX CREDIT. GO
AHEAD DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
I'M ACTUALLY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- ON AB
ONE FORTY FOR THE FILM TAX
CREDITS FOR THE FILM THIS WILL
AFFECT THE STATE'S A MOTION
PICTURE TAX CREDIT EXPANDING
THE CURRENT FILM CREDIT PROGRAM
BY ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION
OVER TWO YEARS THE BILL ALSO
PROVIDES A ONE TIME CREDIT OF
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION VIEWS
OVER MULTIPLE FISCAL YEARS FOR
CONSTRUCTION OF CERTIFIED
MOTION PICTURE INFRASTRUCTURE
OR SOUND STAGES. SO ALTOGETHER
THE TRAILER BILL PROVIDES FOR
THREE HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION IN
TAX CREDITS SPECIFICALLY THE
ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION TAX
CREDIT IS A THIRTY MILLION OVER
TWO YEARS IN TAX CREDITS TO
ENCOURAGE TELEVISION SERIES TO
RELOCATE TO CALIFORNIA FROM
OTHER JURISDICTIONS AND ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION OVER TWO
YEARS IS FOR RECURRING
TELEVISION SERIES TO MAKE UP
FOR A PROJECTED SHORTFALL IN
FUNDS TO COMPLY WITH STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS THAT RECURRING
TELEVISION SERIES RECEIVE
CREDIT ALLOCATIONS. FOR ANY
SUBSEQUENT YEAR THE TELEVISION
SERIES IS PRODUCED IN
CALIFORNIA I'M IN ADDITION THIS
BILL X. INCLUDES EXPANDED
DIVERSITY REPORTING LANGUAGE
FOR THE EXISTING PROGRAM THREE
POINT OH FILM CREDITS AS WELL
AS REQUIREMENT THAT FILMS
PRODUCED ON CERTIFIED
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS MEET OR
MAKE GOOD FAITH EFFORTS TO MEET
DIVERSITY GOALS- I'M JOINED BY
MY COLLEAGUE AND HAPPY TO
RESPOND. TO ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU LET ME SEE IF THERE'S
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
AROUND THE FILM. AND TELEVISION
TAX CREDIT I THINK THE- THE
REVISIONS THAT WE'VE MADE. TO
INCORPORATE MORE SUPPORT FOR.
WHAT WE CALL A TELEVISION BUT
IN EFFECT IT'S THE STREAMING
SERVICES WHICH WE KNOW NOW OUR
IS- SO MUCH PART OF THIS
INDUSTRY. WHEN BEFORE WE WERE
MORE LIMITED TO FILMS ONLY I
THINK IT'S BEEN IS GOING TO BE
A VERY SMART MOVE TO KEEP THOSE
JOBS IN THAT PRODUCTION IN
CALIFORNIA SENATOR STERN. THANK
YOU METAMERGE CHARGE WANTED
THANK YOU AND DECEMBER
LEADERSHIP AND THE GOVERNOR FOR
STEPPING UP AND GETTING THIS
DONE NOW IT'S VERY TIMELY
BECAUSE DECISIONS ARE ALSO
GETTING MADE ABOUT. PRODUCTIONS
RIGHT NOW. SO FOR THIS FALL YOU
KNOW THIS IS THE MAKE OR BREAK
MOMENT WHETHER CALIFORNIA'S
GONNA GET THESE JOBS OR
EMPLOYER OWN PEOPLE OR HAVE
THEM OFF IN GEORGIA OR- SOME
OTHER COUNTRY SO TIMELY AND
CRUCIAL ITEM AND I APPRECIATE
ALSO THE- THE COMPONENT
FOCUSING ON SOUND STAGE BUILDS
OUT SINCE. SOME OF THAT SORT OF
HARD INFRASTRUCTURE TO WHICH WE
THINK WILL CREATE SPACE AND-
MORE PROSPERITY AS WE DIG OUR
WAY OUT OF THIS THANK YOU.
GREAT CENTER PAN. M. CHAIR I
JUST SIGNED UP BRIEFLY
MENTIONED THAT I APPRECIATE
THE- DIVERSITY REPORTING THE
DIVERSITYPROVISIONS AND THIS
IT'S A REPRESENTATION MATTERS
SO MUCH- AND SO IT'S- GREAT TO
SEE THAT WITH OUR STATE FUNDS
THAT WE ALSO WHILE SUPPORTING A
VERY IMPORTANT INDUSTRY HERE IN
THE STATE- IT'S AN INDUSTRY
THAT ALSO IS THE- IS A VERY
PUBLIC FACE FOR STATE AS WELL
AND THAT WE- PORTRAYED THE
DIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA TO THE
REST. OF OUR COUNTRY AND THE
REST OF THE WORLD IN THIS
PROGRAM SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT LET'S MOVE OVER.
TO EIGHTY ONE FORTY EIGHT
PUBLIC RESOURCES TRAILER BILL.
THANK YOU ACTUALLY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- EIGHTY
ONE FORTY EIGHT MAKES VARIOUS
CHANGES RELATED TO PUBLIC
RESOURCES INCLUDING BUT NOT
LIMITED TO. PROVIDING
FLEXIBILITY IS TAX BUT I
FUNDING FOR AREAS EXPERIENCING
DROUGHT CONDITIONS ESTABLISHING
GUIDELINES FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF. THE ONE
MILLION DOLLAR CALIFORNIA WATER
AND WASTEWATER REAR EACH
PAYMENT PROGRAM- AND MAKE
STATUTORY CHANGES TO ADDRESS
THE DECLINING BALANCE AND
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT IN THE OIL
SPILL PREVENTION AND
ADMINISTRATION FUND- WHICH
INCLUDES RAISING A PER BARREL
FEE FROM A SIX POINT FIVE CENTS
TO. EIGHT POINT FIVE CENTS. IT
MAKES TECHNICAL CHANGES NEEDED
TO ESTABLISH THE OFFICE OF
ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE SAFETY
WHICH IS THE SUCCESSOR AGENCY
TO THE WILDFIRE SAFETY
DIVISION- ESTABLISHED IN TWENTY
TWENTY AT THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION- AND LASTLY IT
ESTABLISHES A CALIFORNIA STATE
PARK ADVENTURE PAST PILOT
PROGRAM. WHICH PERMITS ANY
CHILD IN THE FOURTH GRADE. OR
FOURTH GRADE EQUIVALENT AND
THEIR FAMILIES WHO ARE
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS. THE
ABILITY TO VISIT AN ELIGIBLE.
I'M HAPPY TO RESPOND TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHT
LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS ON THE- MAYBE ONE
FORTY EIGHT THREE SOURCES
TRAILER BILL. SENATOR DOLLY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
JUST. IT'S NOT WHAT'S IN THE
BILLS WHAT'S LEFT OUT OF THE
BILL THAT I WANTED TO ASK- LAST
WEEK AS YOU KNOW I. I BROUGHT
UP THE FACT THAT WE HAD PUT.
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
BACK IN THE BUDGET FOR A FIRE
AND- I RATTLED OFF FOR FIVE
PROJECTS JUST IN MY LOCAL
COMMUNITY THAT I KNEW WERE NOT
FUNDED. AND THAT WAS ABOUT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS WORTH AND I
WONDERED WHY- THAT'S NOT IN
THIS BUDGET WE'RE GONNA BE OUT
FOR A MONTH. AND FIRES ARE
RAGING ACROSS MY DISTRICT IN
MANY OTHER DISTRICTS AND WE'RE
RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF FIRE
SEASON AND WE HAVE THE
RESOURCES AVAILABLE. AND WE
HAVE THE PROJECTS AVAILABLE MS
WARNING WHY THAT. THANK YOU
SENATOR DOLLY AND AS WE
MENTIONED LAST WEEK ABOUT
THROUGH EARLY ACTION WE HAVE
FIVE HUNDRED THIRTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS- THAT'S BEEN RELEASED
AND IS ALLOCATED FOR SOME SOME
FOR PROJECTS- IN LOCAL AREAS
AND THERE WILL BE FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS IN REGARDS TO THE
REMAINDER- BUT MY UNDERSTANDING
AND I HAVE MY COLLEAGUE SERGIO-
I GET ARE ON THE LINE FOR SOME
DETAILS MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THOSE FUNDS ARE GOING OUT
NOW. AND THAT THE FUNDS THAT
ARE IN THE BUDGET FOR THAT THIS
YEAR WILL ALSO BE EXPANDED ON
LATER BUT THAT THERE ARE
PROJECTS GOING ON CURRENTLY.
YESTERDAY I GOT A FARM FINANCE
JUST ELABORATE A LITTLE MORE
YEAH THE DEPARTMENTS ARE
CURRENTLY WORKING ON-
IMPLEMENTING THE EARLY ACTION
FUNDING- WAIT WHICH- PRIMARILY
MOST OF IT IS ALREADY COMMITTED
TO THE DIFFERENT PROJECTS AND-
AGAIN IN THE FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION WHICH- IT AND THE
BUDGET WAS HERE LAST WEEK- WITH
THE GOVERNOR HE SIGNED- YOU
KNOW THAT IS NOW. SET TO BE
ACCELERATED INTO THE- NOW
CURRENT YEAR IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO BUT- THE ALLOCATION
OF THOSE FUNDING WILL BE
DISCUSSED OVER SUMMER. SO DO I
WANT TO BE CLEAR I'M TRYING TO
IGURE OUT WHERE I HAVE TO GO
TO GET THE RESOURCES FOR
PROJECTS THAT I. HAVE ON THE
BOOKS THAT ARE SICK WERE. READY
TO GO THEIR SHOVEL READY
PROJECTS AND I'M CONFUSED. SO
THE I KNOW THAT DID DID WE
SPEND ALL THE EARLY ACTION
MONEY I GUESS IS WHAT MY
QUESTION IS. AND IF NOT ARE
THOSE FUNDS AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW
AND IF THEY ARE I WANT TO KNOW
WHERE I GO FIND HIM TO GET INTO
THE PROJECTS THAT I NEEDED. TO
FIND ON THE GROUND. WHAT WHAT I
WAS TOLD LAST WEEK WAS. WE'RE
GONNA PUT IN A TRAILER BILL. SO
ONE TWENTY NINE AND HE WAS.
BUDGET BILL JUNIOR WHICH WAS
SIGNED YESTERDAY HAD THE
RESOURCES IN IT. AND WE ADDED
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION SO ARE WE
GONNA WAIT TILL WE COME BACK TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO SPEND THAT
MONEY THAT'S MY QUESTION. OR IS
THERE MONEY RIGHT NOW AVAILABLE
FOR THE PROJECTS THAT I.
OUTLINED IN THE MANY MORE THAT
I AM FINDING IN IN ALL
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA NOT JUST
MY DISTRICT. YEAH SO THE
ADDITIONAL FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
THAT WAS DISCUSSED IN AT LAST
WEEK'S HEARING THAT WAS- SIGNED
BY THE GOVERNOR AND- BUT YOU GO
JUNIOR. IT IS NOT CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE THAT'S GOING TO BE
ALLOCATED LATER THIS SUMMER THE
SPECIFIC- THAT CATEGORY THE
FUNDING SIMILAR TO ALL THE
EARLY ACTION WAS ALLOCATED. BUT
ON THE QUESTION OF THE EARLY
ACTION MONEY IT'S STILL BEING
DISTRIBUTED CORRECT SO IN TERMS
OF THE QUESTION THAT SENATOR
DOLLY WAS ASKING SHOULDN'T SOME
OF THE CONSERVANCY'S AND OTHERS
THAT ARE RECEIVING THAT MONEY
BE THE ONE TO HAVE THAT SO THAT
HE CULD- DIRECT SUCH PROJECTS
TO APPLYING TO THEM. YEAH AND A
LOT OF THE FUNDING AND
ESPECIALLY CONSERVANCIES TO OUR
UNDERSTANDING HAS BEEN ALREADY
COMMITTED TO CERTAIN PROJECTS
AND SO I THINK THAT THERE'S THE
INFORMATION YOU HAVE ON CERTAIN
PROJECTS WE CAN DEFINITELY
RELAY THE INFORMATION TO THE
AGENCY AND CALIFORNIA THEIR
DEPARTMENTS- BY I. TWO ARE
STANDING A LOT OF THAT HAS BEEN
COMMITTED ALREADY. PROJECTS. SO
JUST ONE LAST COMMENT SO THAT
THAT'S NOT SATISFACTORY TO ME.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS WHICH
WE STATED LAST WEEK WAS THAT
CAL FIRE IS TAKING DOING THEIR
JOB WHICH I LOVE THOSE PEOPLE I
GOT A LOT OF THEM CALLING ME
LAST WEEK SAYING. YOU KNOW I
WOULD I'M NOT BEATING UP ON
THEM THEY HAVE A JOB DOING OR
DOING IT. BUT OUR JOB IS TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE KEEP OUR
COMMUNITY SAFE AND WE HAVE.
MORE MONEY THAN WE'VE EVER SEEN
IN THIS STATE AND WE JUST
SIMPLY CAN'T GET IT OUT. I HAVE
PROJECTS AVAILABLE. THAT ARE
NOT FUNDED MY CONSERVANCIES.
AND MY FIRE SAFE COUNCILS- THE
CONSERVANCY'S ALLOCATED THEM OF
FUNDS YOU JUST STATED THAT
THAT'S CORRECT WHY DON'T WE
GIVE THEM THE MORE FUN MORE FUN
SO THEY CAN ALLOCATE HIM. IF
CAL FIRE'S NOT ABLE TO DO IT
THAT'S THE POINT I'M TRYING TO
DRIVE HOME AND TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE DO THAT I'D- BEEN
TALKING WITH MY- CHAIRMAN OF
SUB TO. ALMOST EVERY DAY AND
I'M FINDING MORE PROJECTS THAN
WHAT I STATED EARLIER THAT I
WANT TO GET FUNDED. NOT NEXT
YEAR I WANT THEM FUNDED NOW SO
I'M HAVING TO. I UNDERSTAND
WHEN IT'S NOT GONNA HAPPEN IN
THIS BUDGET I'M REALLY
FRUSTRATED THE FACT THAT WE'RE
GONNA NEED. NOT PUT MONEY WHERE
IT NEEDS TO GO I'M SORRY IF
THIS ONE AGENCY CAN'T GET IT
OUT BUT THERE ARE OTHER
AGENCIES. THAT DO THIS EVERY
DAY. LIKE THE CONSERVANCY'S AND
THEY- THEY WORK WITH ARE FIRE
SAFE COUNCILS ARE CD'S AND
THEY'RE READY TO DO IT SO. FOR
THE LIFE OF ME I'M I'M VERY
FRUSTRATED RIGHT NOW THAT WE
CAN'T PUT THIS MONEY TO GROUND
WE'RE GONNA WAIT WE'RE GONNA
TAKE A RECESS. AND THEY WERE
GONNA TRY TO FIGURE OUT SO IT'S
GOING TO BE SEPTEMBER. TWO
MONTHS PROBABLY BEFORE. WE GET
MONEY ON THE GROUND AND THEN
IT'LL BE IN THE FALL. SO THAT'S
THE PROBLEM IS THAT IF ONE
AGENCY IS NOT ABLE TO DO IT.
AND OTHERS ARE THAN THIS
REDIRECT THOSE FUNDS. TO THE
AGENCIES THEY CAN GET IT DONE
THIS IS THE END OF THE DAY.
WE'RE STILL DOING THE RIGHT
THING BY GETTING THE PROJECT
DONE. SENATOR DOLLY IN TERMS OF
THE L. THAT SPECIFIES THE- THIS
IS THE NEW PREPARATION THAT WE
JUST RECENTLY DID WE CAN
CERTAINLY YOU CAN CERTAINLY
WORK WITH THAT BUDGET COMMITTEE
THE BUDGET STAFF TO CRAFT THAT
WILDFIRE PACKAGE. SENATOR
FORECASTING. YEAH I DO I DON'T
DISAGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE
FROM- LASSEN COUNTY HAS SAID.
WITH THIS TRAILER BILL DOES IS
IT DOES PUSH OUT THE RULES FOR
THAT FOR- THE UTILITY- THE-
PAYMENT SAID THE ARREARS IT
MAKES IT CLEAR THAT ALSO
EXTENDS TO THE SEWER DISTRICT
CAREER AVERAGES IF PEOPLE HAVE
SEPARATED DISTRICTS AS WELL AS
THE MONEY ON THE ON THE
DROUGHT- WE HAVE BEEN IN
CONVERSATIONS. IT'S WHAT'S NOT
ON HERE IS THE CLIMATE
RESILIENCY PACKAGE AND ALSO THE
WILDFIRE- I WILL SAY SIERRA
NEVADA DID GET SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS AND EARLY ACTION AND
THE OTHER CONSERVANCY'S GOT THE
MONEY THE WORD ON THE STREET IS
THAT THEY HAVE COMMITTED ALL
THAT MONEY TO FIGHT TWO
PACKAGES AND THAT WAS WHAT PART
OF OUR THINKING HERE IN THE
SENATE WAS THAT WE KNEW.
CONSERVANCIES IN PARKS AND FISH
AND WILDLIFE HAS LOTS OF LOTS
OF THINGS TO GO ON SO LOTS OF
PROJECTS THE PESO ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT THE SUBCOMMITTEE
WILL BE LOOKING AT IS WE'VE
MADE RECOMMENDATIONS ON A
BILLION DOLLARS- ON SPENDING.
IT LOOKS IS THAT WITH THE FIVE
pHAS WE'RE UP TO SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FIFTY EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
SO THERE'S A DELTA THERE OF
NUMBERS THAT ARE BETTER OFF
BUT- WE'RE GETTING A LAY OF THE
LAND OF HOW WITH THAT
COMBINATION OF MIX DO WE GIVE
IT TO CAL FIRE AND LET THEM
GIVE OUT GRANTS. TO WE GIVE OUT
FOLLOW OUR EARLY WILDFIRE
ACTIONS WE GIVE. MONEY.
DIRECTLY TO DIFFERENT-
DIFFERENT AGE. I WILL SAY THAT
YOU KNOW THIS IS A THIS TRAILER
BILL HAS A MIX AND MATCH OF
LITTLE THINGS YOU KNOW THEY'VE
GOT. THE GOVERNORS- UP PARKS
BED PROGRAM. FOR FOURTH GRADERS
IS SOMETHING YOU KNOW THAT'S
IT'S A NICE THING AND I SEE
EXAMPLE FOR- CHILDREN TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE THEIR FAMILY TO-
THE STATE PARKS IN. A VERY
IMPORTANT PILOT PROGRAM ON
RECYCLING THAT WE NEED TO DO
AND FOR THE AG COMMUNITY
LEADERS WERE ACTUALLY GIVEN THE
THIRD FRAME WORK ON HOW THE
AIRPORTS GET A DOLE OUT THIS
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR ALTERNATIVES TO
BURNING- THE FEELS I KNOW THAT
THE FOLKS. ARE EAGER TO GET TO
GET THAT MONEY BECAUSE THAT'S
LINING UP- SO WE DO HAVE A LOT
OF WORK TO DO THE BIG THE BIG
ENCHILADAS. AS JOHN SEBASTIAN
SAID. HOT TIME SEPARATE THE
CITY WE WILL BE WORKING IN
SACRAMENTO TO. TO MAKE SURE
THESE PACKAGES GET TOGETHER
SOMETHING THAT THIS THE STATE
MAY END THE SENATE MEMBERS.
SENATOR JOE VOGUE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. AS CHAIR OF THE
INLAND EMPIRE CAUCUS WE HAVE
ADVOCATED FOR ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO ASSIST RESIDENTIAL
AND COMMERCIAL CUSTOMERS WITH
WATER AND WASTE WATER AREA
JUST. AN ADDRESS REVENUE
SHORTFALLS INCURRED BY WATER
ENTERPRISE DOING THE COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC I AM PLEASED
TO SEE THE FUNDING FOR THIS
ISSUE INCLUDED IN THIS BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WHILE MANY
OF THE DETAILS OF THE FUNDING
ALLOCATION PLAN WILL BE A
DANCER WAS SUBSEQUENT PROCESS I
ASK I URGE THAT HESE FUNDS GET
OUT TO OUR COMMUNITIES. AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE- THEY SURELY CANNOT
WAIT TILL UNTIL NOVEMBER.
ADDITIONALLY THIS TRAILER BILL
INCREASES THE FEES ON CRUDE OIL
OR PETROLEUM. PRODUCTS AND
EXPANSIVENESS TO RENEWABLE FUEL.
WE CANNOT CONTINUE TO INCREASE
THE GAS TAXES IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND THEY'RE FULL- I
CANNOT VOTE FOR THE BILL TODAY
BUT I AM GRATEFUL FOR THE GOOD
PARTS IN IT- IN IN IN THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
NELSON. NOT A PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES MY REASON FOR A NO
VOTE ON THIS BILL. IS A PRODUCT
OF INCREASINGLY THE LEGISLATURE
CEDING ITS AUTHORITY OR THE
AUTHORITY OF THE PEOPLE THAT
ELECTED US. TO THE GOVERNOR.
AND AS I UNDERSTAND IT THIS
BILL. THE EXPENDITURE OF THESE
FUNDS ARE SUBJECT TO THE
DETERMINATION OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE TO DETERMINE WHETHER
OR NOT QUOTE THEY ARE NEEDED.
MY THOUGHT IS WHEN THIS
LEGISLATURE ACTS DEALS DONE.
AND I'M NOT WILLING. TO SEE
THAT AUTHORITY. THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH PARTICULARLY IN LIEU OF
WHAT IN LIGHT OF WHAT'S
HAPPENED IN THE LAST YEAR. MORE
SUBSTANTIAL FUNDS WERE NOT
SPEND. TO CLEAN UP THE FORCE IN
THE WILDLANDS THE PRODUCT OF
THAT. AND THE CONSEQUENCES ARE
PAID BY THE PEOPLE THAT WE
REPRESENT WHOSE PROPERTY. LIVE
OR DESTROYED BY THESE FIRES
THAT CONTINUE MY POINT IS I
DON'T LIKE GIVING THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH THAT IS FORTY THUS I
WILL BE A NOBLE. ALL RIGHT
SEEING NO OTHER COMMENTS OR-
MIKE SEVEN WE WILL MOVE TO AB
ONE FIFTY THREE THE CHILD
WELFARE- IN SOCIAL SERVICES
TRAILER BILL GO HEAD DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE. ACTUALLY WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND AB
ONE FIFTY THREE- AND THAT
SOCIAL SERVICES TRAILER BILL
THIS BILL AS PART OF THE TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO BUDGET PACKAGE
MAKES STATUTORY CHANGES TO
IMPLEMENT THE BUDGET ACT
SPECIFICALLY THE BILL INCLUDES
PROVISIONS PERTAINING TO CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES ADMINISTERED
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES INCLUDING.
BUT NOT LIMITED TO ADDRESSING
COMPLEX CARE NEEDS FOR FOSTER
YOUTH THE BUDGET INCLUDES ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY NINE POINT TWO
MILLION TO ASSIST COUNTIES THAT
SERVING A FOSTER YOUTH WITH
COMPLEX NEEDS AND BEHAVIOR
HEALTH CONDITIONS WITHIN
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS YOU THAT
RETURN FROM. AN OUT OF STATE
CONGREGANTS HE SPENT. IT ALSO
INCLUDES- FAMILY REUNIFICATION
CAL WORKS ASSISTANCE. PAYMENT
INFORMATION THE BUDGET INCLUDES
EIGHT POINT EIGHT MILLION
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND I'M GOING FOR
COUNTIES TO CONTINUE PROVIDING
CAL WORKS SERVICES FOR UP TO
ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS. WHEN A
CHILD HAS BEEN REMOVED FROM THE
HOME AND IS RECEIVING. CARE OUR
FAMILY FIRST PREVENTION
SERVICES ACT ONE THE BUDGET
INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED TWENTY TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION IN TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO TO BE EXPENDED
OVER THREE YEARS TO ASSIST
COUNTIES WITH NEW PREVENTION
SERVICES. IMPLEMENTATION
EFFORTS ALLOWABLE UNDER THE NEW
FEDERAL FAMILY FIRST PREVENTION
SERVICES ACT- FOSTER CARE
EMERGENCY ASSISTANCE THE BUDGET
INCLUDES TWENTY FOUR POINT FIVE
MILLION FEDERAL- TEN F. AND
GENERAL FUND. BLOCK GRANT FUNDS
IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO TO
PROVIDE CAREGIVERS WITH UP TO
FOUR MONTHS OF EMERGENCY
ASSISTANCE PAYMENTS PENDING
RESOURCE FAMILY APPROVAL AND UP
TO TWELVE MONTHS FOR CASES THAT
MEET GOOD COST CRITERIA- CWS
AUGMENTATION CHILD WELFARE
SYSTEM AUGMENTATION THE BUDGET
INCLUDES EIGHTY FIVE MILLION
AND ONE TIME SUPPORT- FOR CHILD
WELFARE SERVICES ACTIVITIES-
CHILD WELFARE CARE GIVER
PANDEMIC ASSISTANCE THE BUDGET
INCLUDES. EIGHTY MILLION ONE
TIME CHILD WELFARE CAREGIVER
STIPEND CODE NINETEEN PANDEMIC
ASSISTANCE- AND EMERGENCY
RESPONSE SOCIAL WORKERS THE
BUDGET INCLUDES FIFTY MILLION
SUPPORT INCREASED EMERGENCY
RESPONSE SOCIAL WORKERS. IN
CHILD WELFARE- AND WITH THAT-
I'M HAPPY TO RESPOND TO ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
BECAUSE INIYA- I SAID THIS SIZE
MADE THIS COMMENT IN THE
BEGINNING BUT I AM VERY VERY
PLEASED TO SEE THE PROVISIONS
THAT ARE SUPPORTING OUR FOSTER
YOUTH INCLUDING INCREASED
PAYMENT TO OUR FOSTER FAMILIES
BUT ESPECIALLY THE ELIMINATION
THE ENDING OF SENDING OUR USED
OUT OF STATE FACILITIES SO I'M
REALLY PLEASED TO SEE THAT THE
TRAILER BILL. AND WITH THAT WE
WILL MOVE ON TO- SKEWS ME BABY
ONE FIFTY SIX THE BROADBAND
BILL. YES ACTUALLY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ON EIGHTY
ONE FIFTY SIX THE
COMMUNICATIONS OUR BROADBAND
AVAILABLE- THIS CALL REFLECTS
THE STATE BROADBAND PLAN TO
ACHIEVE EQUITABLE STATEWIDE
ACCESS TO HIGH SPEED BROADBAND
INTERNET SERVICE AND PROPOSES A
SIX BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT
TO EXPAND BROADBAND
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ENHANCE
ACCESS BY CONSTRUCTING AN OPEN
ACCESS NETWORK. AND BY FUNDING
CONSTRUCTION OF PROJECTS THAT
CONNECT UNSERVED HOUSEHOLDS IN
REMOTE AREAS TO THAT NETWORK.
SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL PROVIDES
TWO BILLION TO BE ALLOCATED TO
THE EXISTING CALIFORNIA
ADVANCED SERVICE FUND OUR
CAPITAL PROGRAM TO BUILD
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS FOR COMMUNITIES TO
CONNECT TO WHAT IS CALLED THE
MIDDLE MILE OR THE STATE
INTERNET BACKBONE ONE BILLION
WILL BE ALLOCATED TO RURAL
AREAS AND ANOTHER BILLION WILL
BE ALLOCATED TO. URBAN ON THE
BILL PROVIDES FOR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
TECHNOLOGY AND THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION TO
CONTRACT WITH A THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR THIS THIRD PARTY
ADMINISTRATOR MUST HAVE DEEP
EXPERIENCE IN BUILDING AT WORK
AND WORK WITH THE- CALIFORNIA
WITH CDT MWC. LOCATE AND DESIGN
THE MIDDLE MILE INFRASTRUCTURE
PRIMARILY ON STATE OWNED RIGHT
OF WAY. THE BILL INCLUDES
LANGUAGE THAT SEATS YOU CAN
CONTRACT WITH TOP TRENDS FOR
THE DESIGN AND CONSTRUCTION OF
NEW STATE OWNED. MIDDLE MILE
INFRASTRUCTURE. INCLUDES A
POSITION AT THE DEPARTMENT OF
TECHNOLOGY SERVICES IN THE
PRIMARY POINT OF CONTACT. AS
WELL AS ACCOUNTABILITY AND
REPORTING LANGUAGE INCLUDING
ESTABLISHING A BROADBAND
ADVISORY COMMITTEE- WHICH WILL
BE ESTABLISHED COMPOSED OF
REPRESENTATIVES FROM C. T. QC
CALTRANS THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE THE GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AGENCY. AND FOR
ACTIVE MEMBERS APPOINTED BY THE
ASSEMBLY AND SENATE. OTHER
BROADBAND PLANS THAT ARE
NECESSARY FOR THE STATE. AND
ARE INCLUDED IN THE B. B. J. AS
I PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED THAT
THOSE FUNDS INCLUDE THREE POINT
TWO FIVE BILLION TO BUILD A
STATE ON. OPEN ACCESS MIDDLE
MILE- THE TWO BILLION TO FUND
THE LAST MILE IS INCLUDED IN
THE STRUGGLE- SEVEN HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION FOR A LOAN LOSS
RESERVE ACCOUNTS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ADVANCED SERVICE
FUND TO HELP LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
FOR NONPROFIT. ORGANIZATIONS
SECURE FINANCING FOR
CONSTRUCTION OF LAST MILE
BROADBAND INFRASTRUCTURE. AND
WITH THAT I AM HAPPY TO RESPOND
TO ANY COMMITTEE QUESTION.
THREE ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
ARE BROADBAND YES SENATOR DOLLY.
WHAT SORRY MADAM CHAIR TERE'S
ONLY TWO OF THESE BILLS I
REALLY WANT TO FOCUS IN ON AND
WE'VE ALREADY TALKED ABOUT FIRE
AND THE NEXT ONE IS BROADBAND
SO. MY QUESTION IN MY DISTRICT
A HUNDRED THIS IS THE NOT A LOT
OF DETAIL AT LEAST I COULD FIND
IN THIS. ABOUT ACTUALLY HOW
THIS IS GONNA WORK- I
UNDERSTAND THAT THE. THE
UTILITIES ARE. NOT OUR FRIENDS
THEY DON'T USE OUR RESOURCES
AND THEY DON'T HOOK UP PEOPLE
AND THEY ONLY GO WHERE THEY CAN
MAKE MONEY AND SO I UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE PROCESS HERE IS JUST
AS FAR AS- TRYING TO. DO
SOMETHING THAT ACTUALLY SERVES
THE PEOPLE OF MY DISTRICT A
HUNDRED BY MEGABYTES PER SECOND
DOWNLOAD IS FAR MORE THAN MOST
PEOPLE ACTUALLY HAVE. IN THIS
BILL THAT'S GOING TO BE THE
STANDARD FOR UNDER ORDERS. FOR
SERVER UNDERSERVED TWENTY FIVE
THREE SEEMS MORE LIKE AN ACTOR
STANDARD FOR TRULY ON UNDER
SERVED. FOR THE LAST MILE RULE
FUNDING FORMULA- WAS A HUNDRED.
MEGABYTES PER SECOND THE
THRESHOLD CHOSEN FOR
PRIORITIZING DISTRIBUTION OF
THAT ONE HUNDRED BILLION AND
NOT THE TWENTY FIVE THREE. SO I
THINK THIS IS GONNA BE THE
RITUALLY UNDERSERVED ARE GONNA
TRY TO MEET A HIGHER STANDARD
THAN WHAT. A STANDARD OF TWENTY
FIVE THREE WOULD BE SO CAN YOU
KIND OF GIVE ME SOME. THOUGHT
PROCESS ABOUT HOW YOU GOT. TO
THAT. CALCULATION. ALI I WILL
TURN THE QUESTION OVER TO ONE
OF MY COLLEAGUES- WHO'S BEEN
WORKING ON BROADBAND. YOUR
FINANCE AND- THE SO AS IT IS I
THINK- THIS IS ALREADY NOTED-
THE MAJORITY OF THE FUNDING FOR
THIS. PROPOSAL COMES FROM THE
ARC OF FUNDS AND SO- TO A
CERTAIN EXTENT SUCCESS SO THEY
HAVE THE HUNDRED DOWN CERTAINLY
IS PART OF THE- WHAT'S THE
FEDERAL BIKE US TO PURSUE- BUT
IN GENERAL- YOU KNOW WORKING
WITH- YEAH. THE PUBLIC
UTILITIES COMMISSION AND- AND
YOU KNOW OTHER INDUSTRY EXPERTS
A HUNDRED- HUNDRED DOWN IS-
THAT SAID IT'S A GOOD FUTURE
PROOF MEASURE- AND IT'S AND
IT'S SOMETHING THE STOCKMARKET
TECHNOLOGICALLY ACHIEVABLE. SO
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT- MMHM WHEN
WE TALK ABOUT THE WORK OF
COURSE BUT THE MIDDLE MILE AND
LAST MILE AND SO- BUT THE
TARGET REALLY IS- TO IDENTIFY
FIRST TO THOSE WHO ARE ON THE
SERVER AND SO REFERENCE TO
TWENTY FIVE SIX AND IF IT IS
THAT- THAT'S A SERVICE THAT'S
NOT FAST ENOUGH TO ALLOW FOR-
YOU MULTIPLE USERS THE WAY THAT
I THINK PEOPLE IT'S NOW BECOME-
USED TO R. AND HAD TO GET USED
TO. THE CODE AND EVERYTHING AND
SO THE IDEA FOR THE TWENTY FIVE
DOWN IS THAT- ANYTHING BELOW
THAT IS NOT. IT'S NOT FUN OR
NOT AND SO AS FUND PROJECTS WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT. THE
PROJECTS ARE ABLE TO OPERATE AT
THE HUNDRED LEVEL. BUT I WOULD
JUST SHARE WITH YOU THAT IS AN
AREA I'VE WORKED A LOT AND- A
HUNDRED MEGABYTES PER SECOND
VERSUS TWENTY FIVE SO THAT
MEANS THAT ANYBODY THAT HAS
TWENTY FIVE OR- OR IS UNDER A
HUNDRED. IS CONSIDERED
UNDERSERVED SO THAT MEANS THAT
THEY HAVE SOMETHING IF THEY IF
THEY'RE- TWENTY FIVE OR- ABOVE
IF YOU'RE TWENTY FIVE BELOW IF
YOU HAVE NOTHING. HE WOULD BE
HAPPY TO HAVE TWENTY FIVE THREE
AND THAT'S MY POINT IS THAT
MOST THIS MONEY'S GONNA GO TO
AREAS THAT. R. HAVE SERVICE BUT
JUST NOT A HUNDRED. AND THAT
THAT'S GOING TO CARVE OUT A
WHOLE BUNCH OF PEOPLE IN IN
VERY IN AREAS WHERE THEY DON'T
HAVE IT SO I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
THAT THAT POLICY AND HOW IT
GETS HOW IT PLAYS OUT WHEN WE
EXPANDED I UNDERSTAND WE GOT TO
GET THIS ON THE GROUND WE GOT
TO GET IT DONE BECAUSE THIS IS.
FEDERAL DOLLARS- SO I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING WE SHOULD LOOK
AT MAYBE IN SOME FOLLOW UP
LANGUAGE BECAUSE WE'RE GOING TO
MISS A WHOLE BUNCH OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE NOT SERVED AND WE'RE
GONNA SPEED UP PEOPLE'S
SERVICES THAT ALREADY ARE
SERVED. I THINK THAT'S A
PROBLEM WITH THIS PIECE A
LETTER WITH THIS PROPOSAL THE
OTHER THING I WANT TO ASK ABOUT
IS THE MIDDLE MILE. WHEN YOU
WHEN YOU WHEN THAT WHISTLE
GONNA BE A GOVERNMENT RAN.
INTERNET SERVICE THIS IS THIS
IS DONE BY THE FUNDS ARE COMING
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND
FROM THE STATE FUNDS THAT WE'RE
PUTTING IN. AND ALL THE
MONOPOLIES THAT WE HAVE THE
FIVE BIG MONOPOLIES THAT DON'T
HELP US OUT WHICH IS EIGHTEEN
T. VERIZON- SPRINT. AND ALL THE
BIG UTILITIES OUT THERE THAT
THAT HAVE ALL THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND WE'RE GONNA
PUT THE MIDDLE MILE IN BUT WHO
WERE WHO WERE GONNA HOOK UP TO.
AND WE'RE GONNA TRY TO HOOK UP
TO THEIR- TO THEIR SOURCE. AND
THEN OFFERED. TO THEIR
CUSTOMERS I DON'T BELIEVE
THEY'RE GOING TO BE WANTING TO
PARTICIPATE. IN LETTING US GET
ON THIS BACKBONE IT'S THE
BACKBONE IS NOT OWNED BY THE
PUBLIC IT'S OWNED BY PRIVATE
COMPANIES AND IF WE'RE GONNA
PUT THE MIDDLE MILE AND THEN
TRY TO HOOK UP TO THAT AND GO
OUT AND SERVE UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES I DON'T SEE WHAT
THE INCENTIVE FOR THEM TO BE
ABLE. TO LET US COOK IN THE
BACK OF THE HOUSE THAT GONNA
WORK. YES SO- PART OF THE
TROUBLE DOES IS IT PROVIDES FOR
A- THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATOR
THAT HAS- BROAD EXPERIENCE IN
THE IN THIS- IN THIS INDUSTRY-
AND SO- BUT BUT THE INTENT IS
REALLY TO- TO BUILD OUR TRIP
TO- TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
AN OPEN ACCESS- LITTLE MILD
THAT DOES THAT TIES INTO THE
BAN LAST MILE. COMMUNITIES CAN
TIE INTO. AND SO- THE- SO THE-
INDUSTRY AND THAT THAT THEY
CURRENTLY HAS- INFRASTRUCTURE
THERE- CERTAINLY WE WANT TO
BUILD SOMETHIN WE DON'T NEED A
BILL RIGHT AND SO- THE- WE
WOULD WORK WITH INDUSTRY WE
WOULD WORK THROUGH A THIRD
PARTY ADMINISTRATOR- AND THEN
TRY TO USE WHAT'S AVAILABLE WHO
CAN GET LONG TERM ACCESS TO IT-
BUT TO THE EXTENT THAT- THAT
WERE UNABLE TO GET THAT THEN WE
WOULD NEED TO- THEN. WE NEED TO
GO AHEAD AND BUILD- BUILD OUT
THE SYSTEM THERE SO THAT IN THE
END WE HAVE A MIDDLE MILE
SYSTEM THAT REACHES ALL OF THE
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE. WELL
I WOULD SAY THAT. WE'RE GONNA
PUT MIDDLE MILE. RIGHT
ALONGSIDE A PRIVATE PROVIDERS
MIDDLE MILE. I HAVE IT THROUGH
ALL THROUGHOUT MY DISTRICT AND
SOMETHING I'VE BEEN VERY
FRUSTRATED WITH THE UTILITIES
IS I'VE SAID IT THREE TIMES ON
THIS FLOOR WE HAVE THE I. FIVE
QUARTER GOES ALL THE WAY FROM
CALIFORNIA TO WASHINGTON AND
THERE'S FIBER LAID. LOTS OF
FIBER LAID RIGHT UP THROUGH
THERE AND A LOT OF IT ALONG THE
RAILROAD LINES AS WELL. AND
THEY DON'T ALLOW ME TO TAP INTO
IT SO THEY'RE THEY'RE GONNA
ALLOW YOU TO TAP INTO THAT
SOMEWHERE. TO HOOK UP MY
COMMUNITY BECAUSE YOU HAVE
MIDDLE MAN THAT'S THERE BUT YOU
GOT IT CONNECTED THERE'S BEEN
ON RAMP. THERE'S BEEN OFFERING
UP. TO GET THE ON RAMP YOU HAVE
TO TAKE IT FROM SOMEBODY'S
PRIVATE. SOME PRIVATE COMPANIES
BACKBONE. THAT'S THE CONCERN I
PASSED EARLIER. BUT YOU'RE
BASICALLY SAYING WE'RE GONNA
BUILD OUR OWN NETWORK RIGHT
NEXT TO THEIRS. AND THAT
SOMEHOW IS GOING TO SERVE OUR
COMMUNITIES. THANK YOU THIRTY
DOLLARS SENATOR MCGUIRE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MADAM CHAIR IN
ODYSSEY ON THE ISSUE OF
BROADBAND. AT FIRST AND
FOREMOST I WANT TO SAY THANK
YOU TO OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
BEAVER AND- SHARES FRUSTRATION
REGARDING A LACK OF ACCESS UP
FOR HIGH SPEED INTERNET. I'M A
FIRM BELIEVER THAT THIS
PANDEMIC IS REALLY SHINE THE
SPOTLIGHT. ON THE MASSIVE
DISPARITIES THAT EXIST WHETHER
IT'S IN A SMALL TOWN IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA- OUR INNER
CITIES IN DOWNTOWN LA WHEN IT
COMES TO THE ISSUE OF INTERNET.
MILLIONS ACROSS THE STATE ARE
THE ARE ON THE WRONG SIDE. OF
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE. AND I'M A
FIRM BELIEVER THIS PROJECT'S
LEGACY. WILL BE IT'S THE
LARGEST ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
INITIATIVE THAT HAS BEEN
LAUNCHED. IN PARTICULAR FOR
RURAL CALIFORNIA. IN OVER A
CENTURY. SO BOTTOM LINE IS THIS
I SHARE. THE GOOD SENATORS
FRUSTRATION. ABOUT MIDDLE MILE
BUT HERE'S THE TRUTH IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA WHEN IT COMES TO
MIDDLE MILE. DIRT LITERALLY
THOUSANDS OF MIDDLE MILE LINES
THAT RUN THROUGH RURAL
CALIFORNIA. THE INCUMBENTS ONLY
ACCESS TO THAT MIDDLE MILE.
THEY FORCE SOME OF THE POOREST
COMMUNITIES IN AMERICA TO PAY
EXORBITANT FEES TO TAP INTO A-
IN THOSE COMMUNITIES SIMPLY
CAN'T AFFORD IT. WHICH MEANS.
WE HAVE A HUGE SWATHS OF THE
STATE THAT ARE UNDERSERVED WHEN
IT COMES TO NOT JUST ON NOT NOT
JUST HI SPEED INTERNET BUT EVEN
DIAL UP. SO IS IT RIDICULOUS
THAT THIS STATE IS GOING TO
HAVE TO BUILD A SECOND LINE
REDUNDANT LYING NEXT TO
INCUMBENT LYING YOU'RE RIGHT IT
IS BUT WE'RE NOT IN IT FOR THE
PROFIT. THIS STATE IS IN IT FOR
THE PEOPLE. AND MORE
COMPETITION WILL BRING DOWN THE
PRICES FOR EVERYONE IN THE
STATE. THERE'S THREE POINT TWO
FIVE BILLION FOR MIDDLE MILE
THAT HIGH CAPACITY FIBER LINE
THAT IS THE HIGHWAY- OF WHAT
WILL BE ONE OF AMERICA'S
LARGEST BROADBAND PROJECTS- I
KNOW THAT THE GOVERNOR THE
LEGISLATURE IS VERY FOCUSED ON
BRINGING ON AN EXPERIENCED
NONPROFIT TO BE ABLE TO OVERSEE
IT. AND RIGHTFULLY SO IT IS
GOING TO HAVE A WORSE FOR
STRATEGY WE HAVE TO FOCUS ON
THOSE WHO DON'T HAVE SERVICE
FIRST THEN GO TO LOWES WHO ARE
UNDERSERVED. IN THE REASON WHY
WE HAVE TO HAVE TWO POINT SEVEN
FIVE BILLION FOR LAST MILE IS
TO ALLOW FOR COMMUNITIES TO BE
ABLE TO BUILD OUT THEIR OWN
SYSTEMS THREE TO CONNECT TO
THAT NEW. MIDDLE MILE THAT WILL
BE BUILT BY THE PUBLIC. I'LL
SAY THIS. THIS BUDGET HAS
CHANGED SINCE CHAIR SKINNER AND
IN PARTICULAR- TO MAC INTO
SPEAKER RENDON GOT INVOLVED. ON
THE LAST MILE ALONE. THERE IS
IT LEASED OUT OF THAT TWO POINT
TWO FIVE BILLION AT LEAST ONE
BILLION WILL GO TO RURAL
COMMUNITIES THIS IS A GAME
CHANGER. FOR LAST MILE RIGHT
NOW THERE ARE ZERO DOLLARS THAT.
TRINIDAD OR CRESCENT CITY.
WEAVERVILLE- HAYFORK CAN US
ZERO DOLLARS AVAILABLE FOR THEM
TO BE ABLE TO BUILD OUT THEIR
OWN BROADBAND. NUMBER TWO.
WE'VE INCREASED THE LOAN LOSS
AMOUNT FROM TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION IT'S TWO TO SEVEN
HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION IN THIS
BUDGET WHAT IS THE LONE LOSS
AMOUNT IT WILL ALLOW RURAL
CITIES AND COUNTIES IN UNDER
SERVED. METROPOLITAN AREAS THE
DEAL WITH THE BOND AGAINST THE
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
TO BE ABLE TO BUILD OUT THEIR
SYSTEM. IT'S A GAME CHANGER.
THERE'S GOING TO BE FIFTY
MILLION. IN AN UPCOMING.
ALLOCATION FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE GRANTS FOR RURAL
COMMUNITIES THE BILL TO COVER
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ENGINEERING
WE'RE LEARNING FROM MISTAKES IN
THE PAST WITH LARGE BUDGET
PUBLIC PROJECTS. IN DOING A
WAIVER FOR SEQUEL. I'M WITHIN
THE CALTRANS RIGHT AWAY. WE
SHOULD BE APPLAUDING THIS
EFFORT RIGHT NOW- THE LAST
THING I'LL SAY IS THIS. THE
GOAL OF THIS PROJECT IS NOT
JUST TO CONNECT. PEOPLE BUT
IT'S ALSO TO CONNECT OUR MOST
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
MAKES OUR COMMUNITIES THRIVE
IT'S GONNA CONNECT FEDERALLY
QUALIFIED HEALTH CENTERS. RURAL
HEALTH CENTERS HOSPITALS THANK
GOD K. TWELVE PUBLIC SCHOOLS
THERE ARE COMMUNITIES ON THE
NORTH COAST WHERE KIDS WERE
SPENDING. TWO HUNDRED TO THREE
HUNDRED DOLLARS EVERY FREAKING
MONTH. THE ACCESS SATELLITE
INTERNET. IT'S UNACCEPTABLE AND
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO RELY ON
THE PRIVATE INDUSTRY TO DO GOOD
INPUT GOOD OVER PROFIT WE'RE
GONNA BE WAITING ANOTHER FIFTY
YEARS. SO LET'S GET OUR ACT
TOGETHER LET'S GET THIS THING
BUILT LET'S CONNECT OUR
LIBRARIES. LET'S CONNECT OUR
FIRE HOUSES ARE HOSPITALS IN
OUR KIDS TO THE INTERNET TO THE
DESERT. THERE ARE OVER A DOZEN
OTHER STATES THAT HAVE DONE
THIS WE ARE THE LAND OF
OPPORTUNITY HERE IN CALIFORNIA
IT IS ABOUT TIME THAT WE DEPLOY
THIS HIGH SPEED INTERNET TO THE
MOST UNCERTAIN UNDERSERVED
RESIDENTS HERE IN THE WEST
COAST AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AND I VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MCGUIRE WOODS WELL DONE. ANY
OTHER COMMENT OR. GOOD NOT TO
FOLLOW. LET'S GO TO AB ONE
SIXTY THE CANNABIS CLEANUP. YES
ACTUALLY WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ON EIGHTY ONE SIXTY
THIS BILL AMONG OTHER
PROVISIONS MAKES CHANGES TO A.
B. ONE FORTY ONE WHICH
ESTABLISHED THE APARTMENT UP
CANNABIS CONTROL- SPECIFICALL
THIS BILL TERRIFIES FOR
SUBSEQUENT RENEWALS FOR ALL
PROVISIONAL LICENSES HOW TO
DEMONSTRATE COMPLIANCE. FOR
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THAT HAVE
MADE AGREEMENTS ON THE
COMPLIANCE WITH THE STATE THAT
WERE NOT MENTIONED WITH. MAYBE
ONE FORTY ONE. SPECIFIES THAT
IF THE LEAD AGENCY COMPLIES A
SEQUEL- THEY ARE NOT SUBJECT TO
COMPLY WITH THE QUICK
BENCHMARKS INCLUDED IN THIS
BILL. VERIFIES THAT JULY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY THREE IS THE DATE
WHEN THE CONDITIONS GO INTO
EFFECT FOR SUBSEQUENT RENEWALS
FOR ALL PROVISIONAL LICENSES.
ALLOWS THE DEPARTMENT OF
CANNABIS CONTROL TO ISSUE A
PROVISIONAL LICENSE FOR A LOCAL
EQUITY LICENSE APPLICATION THAT
INCLUDES CULTIVATION. IF
CERTAIN CRITERIA ARE MET UNTIL
JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. DELAYS THE DEADLINE WHEN
THE DEPARTMENT OF FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE ESTABLISHES A
PROCESS FOR LICENSED
CULTIVATORS TO ESTABLISH-
APPELLATIONS OF ORIGINTO
JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
IT REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
CANNABIS CONTROL TO INCLUDE THE
AMOUNT OF TRADE SAMPLES THAT
MAY BE PROVIDED TO LICENSEE
WHEN ADOPTING REGULATIONS.
RELATED TO TRADE SAMPLES. IT'S
TEN THOUSAND GENERAL FUND FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS
CONTROL TO IMPLEMENT PROVISIONS
OF THIS BILL AND MAKES OTHER
TECHNICAL IN CLARIFYING
CHANGES. I'M JOINED BY MY
COLLEAGUES AND AM HAPPY TO
RESPOND TO ANY QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. LET'S SEE IF
THERE ARE ANY ANY ON. THISON
THE CANNABIS TRAILER BUILT ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. CORRECT
C. NG NINE I AM GOING TO GO TO
THE PUBLIC COMMENT PORTION OF
OUR HEARING. AND I'M GONNA
FIRST LOOK TO THIS HEARING ROOM
TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY PUBLIC
WHO WANTS TO SPEAK TO US I SEE
SOMEONE COMING UP TO THE MIKE
NOW. EXCELLENT YOU MAY BEGIN.
GO AHEAD. FIVE WE HAVE THE
MICRON FOR THAT INDIVIDUAL.
RIGHT WHICH CARD THEN YOU CAN
COME UP TO MIKE SAY YOUR NAME
AND BEGIN. I STILL CAN'T HEAR
YOU SORRY. LET'S TRY AGAIN.
NOPE. POLITIES A LITTLE WORK
CLICK HERE.
J. BUT STILL NOT
WORKING HOLD ON WE GOT
TECHNICAL GLITCHES HERE. IN THE
MEANTIME I WILL LOOK TO THE
OVERFLOW ROOM THERE IS NO ONE
IN THE OVERFLOW ROOM- AND WHILE
WE'RE WAITING TO MAKE SURE THAT
MIKE. GETS TURNED ON I WILL SAY
THAT. THOSE OF YOU WANT TO MAKE
A COMMENT BY THE PHONE LINE.
THROUGH OUR TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE THE PHONE NUMBER IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. THREE THREE
SIX FOUR FOUR THREE SEVEN. AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. EIGHT TWO
SIX EIGHT FOUR TWO EIGHT AND WE
WILL GO TO THE PHONE MODERATOR.
IN A MOMENT- BUT I WILL FIRST
TURN TO THE PERSON WHO IS HERE
IN THE COMMITTEE HEARING ROOM
WITH US AND TURNED HIM FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH CHAIR OF
THE HALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
I LIKE TO JUST SUPPORT THREE OF
THE BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA
FIRST- EIGHTY ONE THIRTY TWO
THE POST SECONDARY EDUCATION
FOR THE MAIL WE THINK THE
COMMITTEE AND THE SENATE. AND
STAFF- FOR REMOVING- SECTION
SIXTY SEVEN FROM THAT BILL THAT
WE OPPOSE- WE ALSO ARE HERE TO-
SUPPORT EIGHTY ONE FORTY FOUR-
THE- TAX CREDIT- BILL FOR-
STUDIO CONSTRUCTION THANK THE
STAFF OF THE COMMITTEE AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE FOR THEIR
HARD WORK ON THAT IMPORTANT
ROOSEVELT. AND FINALLY- EIGHTY
ONE FIFTY SIX WE ARE ALSO IN
SUPPORT- THE BROADBAND BILL- WE
COULD HAVE SAID IT BETTER THAN-
SENATOR MCGUIRE THIS IS A
CRITICAL BILL AND WILL LEAD
ONLY TO- INCREASE ACCESS TO THE
INTERNET FOR- THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA MILLIONS
PROBABLY- BUT ALSO CREATE A LOT
OF GOOD. MIDDLE CLASS JOBS AS
WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHTS IS THERE ANYONE
IN THE GALLERY ONCE MAKE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON OUR BUDGET TRAILER
BILLS. ALL RIGHT SEEING NINE
PHONE MODERATOR YOU CAN- START
WITH THOSE WHO ARE CALLING IN.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE MINUTE THEN
ZERO THE COMMAND AGAIN ONE
MINUTE THEN ZERO AND FIRST
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
PAMELA KIDS REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION WE JUST WANTED TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR. THE
HELLO BILL. EIGHTY ONE THIRTY
THREE THE PERFECTLY THE
CHILDREN AND YOUTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INITIATIVES. AND
ADDRESSING THE MENTAL HEALTH
NEEDS OF STUDENTS ALSO THE
IMAGE ACTUALLY SHE- AMENDMENTS
TO THE BILL THAT WOULD SERVE-
NOT ONLY- THE PARTNERSHIPS WITH
EDUCATIONAL AND COUNTY MENTAL
HEALTH ENTITIES- BUT OTHERS WHO
CAN HELP STUDENTS ADDRESSED-
THEIR MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS AND
DURING THIS TIME. WE ALSO. WANT
TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT FOR
EIGHTY ONE FIFTY SIX THE-
BROADBAND BILL SPECIFICALLY
ADDRESSING THE NEEDS- OF THE
THIRD PARTY ADMINISTRATOR TO
HAVE SOME EXPERIENCE WITH
SCHOOLS AND UNIVERSITIES. AS
WELL AS- ALSO PRIORITIZING
SCHOOLS AS OF SOME OF THE
AREAS- FOR EXTENDING HIGH
BANDWIDTH CONNECTIONS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
FOR YOUR WORK THIS YEAR THANK
YOU. WHY DID. TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
TERRIBLE EIGHTEEN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
REGISTERING OUR SUPPORT FOR
EIGHTY ONE THIRTY THREE THE
HELP TRAILER BILL LEADER
SPECIFICALLY VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE BEHAVIOR HEALTH
INFRASTRUCTURE CONTINUAL
PROPOSAL AND THE CHILDREN AND
YOUTH BEHAVIOR HEALTH
INITIATIVE PROPOSAL LASTLY I
WANTED TO MENTION THAT WE ARE
NEUTRAL ON TH INCOMPETENT TO
STAND TRIAL DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS PROPOSAL. BUT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO PARTICIPATING IN THE
WORK GROUP TO FIND A SOLUTION.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. K. LINE.
TWO HUNDRED SIXTY TWO. HI THIS
IS JUSTIN GARRETT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES- APPRECIATE THE STRONG
INVESTMENTS FOR VULNERABLE
CHILDREN AND OLDER ADULTS IN
THE HUMAN SERVICES TRAILER
BILLS ESPECIALLY THE INCLUSION
OF OUR SPONSORED BUDGET
PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE CONTINUITY
FOR THE ICE THAT STATE COUNTY
SHARING RATIO AND 10% OVER
THREE YEARS TO. BARBER WE DO
REMAIN STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THE
HIGH SCHOOL PENALTY PROVISIONS
OF EIGHTY ONE THIRTY FIVE I
NEED TO REACH AGREEMENT FAR
ABOVE THE HISTORIC PACE OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS AND
INVESTED HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS FOR A WAGE INCREASE.
pINCREASE OVER THE PRIOR PENALTY
AND PUNISHES ALL THOSE COUNTIES
THAT DID THE RIGHT THING AND
INCREASE WAGES FOR PROVIDERS
NOT JUST A VERY SMALL NUMBER
THE DATE YET TO REACH AN
AGREEMENT. THE 7% PENALTY
AMOUNT WILL BE USED TO LEVERAGE
COUNTED INTO THE GREEN TO WAGE
INCREASES AT SOME COUNTIES
CAN'T AFFORD WITHOUT TAKING
MONEY FROM OTHER PROGRAMS THIS
CREATES RISK FOR THE PROGRAMS
WITHIN REALIGNMENT WAS UNLESS
GROWTH FUNDING BEING AVAILABLE
FOR PUBLIC HEALTH AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. PROGRAMS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU.
BLIGHTED TWO HUNDRED NINETY
ONE. THANK YOU MY NAME IS MARTY
EMOTO I'M A FAMILY MEMBER ALSO
A MEMBER OF THE DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICES PASSPORT MEMBER OF THE
MASTER PLAN FOR AGING
SUBCOMMITTEES THIS ONE
EXPRESSED STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE JOB- DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM.
THE BILL- THE PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES TRAILER BILL THEM-
EVEN SERVICES AND HELP TRAILER
BILLS SECTION AREA OF EDGE OF
SCIENCES P. IDEA SAYS A SESSION
AREA THE SEVEN PERCENT-
REDUCTION ELIMINATION AND- JUST
ONE OF A GROUP THAT I SHOULD.
SAY THAT WE TOTALLY AGREE WITH
THE CHAIRS SENATOR SKINNER'S
CHARACTERIZATION OF THE BUDGET
BEING TRANSFORMING AND BECAUSE
OF THAT IT DOES MUCH TOWARD THE
GOALS OF- REDUCING DISPARITIES
IN ACHIEVING EQUITY AND JUST
WANT TO DO A SHOUT OUT TO YOU-
SENATORS ADMIN AND PAN IN THEIR
ROLES AS CHAIR OF SUB THREE IN
REALLY LOOKING OUT FOR ALL OF
US. AND LASTLY- HOW MUCH WANT
TO DO IT A SHADOW TO SENATOR
NIELSEN AND LET YOU KNOW
SENATOR NIELSEN HOW MUCH WE AS
DISABILITY ADVOCATES EVEN
THOUGH WE DON'T ALWAYS AGREE
WITH WHAT YOU SAY WE DO LISTEN
TO YOU WE RESPECT YOU AND WE
ALSO RESPECT YOUR SERVICE AND
LASTLY A BIG SHOUT OUT TO THE
COMMITTEE STAFF WHO HAVE DONE
TREMENDOUS WORK AND ALSO A COPY
TO THE. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. HELLO. EIGHTEEN
HUNDRED SIX. CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU THANK YOU
MY NAME IS PAUL MCGOVERN FOM
WIRE AMERICA I'VE JUST STARTED
MY TIMER AND I WANT TO SAY
THAT- YOU HAVE SOME EXCELLENT
RESOURCES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE EXPERTS IN
BROADBAND WE HAVE BEEN SO FOR
THE LAST SIX YEARS AND WE WORK
CLOSELY WITH BRUCE KUSHNICK
FROM THE REGULATORS. THEY HAD A
VERY IMPORTANT A LAWSUIT THAT
POINT THE STATE BUT EXACTLY HOW
TO SOLVE THE DIGITAL DIVIDE BY
RECOVERING NOT JUST THIS TWO TO
THREE BILLION YOU HAVE ON THE
TABLE BETWEEN TWELVE TO FIFTEEN
BILLION YOU CAN RECOVER FROM
THE INCUMBENT. CLAIMING FALSELY
OWNERSHIP OVER THOSE FIBER
OPTIC BACKBONE LINES IT IS NOT
THERE AS IT WAS PAID FOR BY THE
PUBLIC ON OUR PHONE BILLS FROM
NINETEEN NINETY THREE TO THE
PRESENT DON'T BELIEVE THAT
PROPAGANDA DON'T LET THEM. THIS
IS A CALL AT YOU CAN CONNECT TO
THEM YOU JUST HAVE TO HAVE THE
COURAGE IN ORDER TO DO SO IN
pREASON TO PUBLICATIONS THAT MR
KUSHNER CALLED BOTH THE
UNREDACTED REPORT BY CALIFORNIA
COMMISSION ABOUT EIGHTEEN T.
CALIFORNIA THAT DOES YOUR STATE
PUBLIC TELECOMMUNICATIONS
UTILITY THAT DOES MANAGE THAT
PUBLIC ASSETS. FOR THE BENEFIT
OF THE PUBLIC THIS IS WHAT YOU
CAN DO YOU CAN. ACCESS TO THAT
USE YOUR MONEY WISELY IT OPENS
UP ALL THAT MONEY NOW TO
CONNECT THE COMMUNITIES. THE
FACT THAT YOU HAVE ACCESS TO IT
ANOTHER ARTICLE FOR HIM IN JUNE
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE GET THE
MONEY BACK FROM THOSE WHO
CREATED THE DIGITAL DIVIDE.
WELCOME TO VERIZON AT&T AT ALL
THIS IS IN YOUR PUBLIC RECORD
YOU DON'T NEED TO PAY ATTENTION
TO IT WE. GIVE YOU ACTUAL
DEFAMATION TO- AND EVERYTHING
MEMBER JOB YESTERDAY. WE WILL
BE SETTING MEETINGS YOU TO
EDUCATE YOU AND I COULD DROP.
YEAH THIS IS YOUR ONE IN A LONG
TIME. PLEASE PLEASE WRAP UP.
THANK YOU. SEVENTY SIX THANK
YOU FOR. GOOD EVENING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS J. NEAL WITH
CAL STATUS OF COUNTIES CLICK TO
ASSOCIATE THAT ARE PAID ON
BROADWAY BILL WITH COMMENTS OF
SENATOR MCGUIRE. AND I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK ALL OF THE
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
THE PRO TEM AND SO MANY OTHERS
AND OF COURSE THE STAFF FOR ALL
THE HARD WORK YOU GETTING US TO
WHERE- YOU ARE TODAY ON THE
VERGE OF PASSING THIS MOMENT
IS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. FIND
IT. TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY SIX. DO
YOU EVER TURN IN FOR THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA WE
SUPPORT AP ONE THIRTY TWO THANK
YOU FOR THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND STAFF FOR ALL YOUR WORK ON
THE FILM. THANK YOU. BY. TWO
HUNDRED NINETY NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON OUR CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CHRIS STOPS MANNER AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF STATE
COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL EMPLOYEES
ASKED ME TO PORT THE
ESTABLISHMENT OF THE CHILDREN
AND YOUTH APRIL HEALTH
INITIATIVE THAT IS WELL IT'S
THE PRIMARK FOR THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH CONTINUUM INFRASTRUCTURE
PROGRAM WITH AN EIGHTY ONE
THIRTY THREE. EIGHTY ONE THIRTY
ONE TO INCREASE REIMBURSEMENT
RATES FOR CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
AND CHILL OUT FOR A JOINT LABOR
MANAGEMENT COMMITTEES
REFLECTING THE RECENT
BARGAINING AGREEMENTS. ASK ME
ALSO SUPPORTS EIGHTY ONE THIRTY
FIVE WHICH IMPROVES THE IN HOME
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES PROGRAM.
SPECIFICALLY TO PERMANENT
RESTORATION OF THE 7% CUT ANY
INCLUSION OF CRITICAL
BARGAINING TOOLS. DIFFICULT
PENALTY FOR COUNTIES THAT
BARGAIN IN BAD FAITH AND
MAINTAINING THE COST SHARING
RATIO BETWEEN THE STATE AND
COUNTY. FINALLY WE WOULD LIKE
TO ALIGN OUR COMMENTS TO
EXPRESS APPRECIATION FOR THE
TIRELESS WORK OF THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND STAFF.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. A LINE OF
THREE HUNDRED ONE. THIS MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS MIGHT CAROL WITH
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY. WE WE HAVE
EXTRAORDINARY GRATITUDE FOR THE
LEGISLATURE AND THE GOVERNOR-
TO COMING UP WITH THE SAME
AMAZING BUDGET- AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THE WORK OF EVERYONE
INVOLVED THE STAFF AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
AND THE AGENCY THEN. ALL THE
APPLICATIONS WERE VERY GRATEFUL
FOR ALL OF THE WORK AND THE-
PROGRESS THAT WE'RE MAKING BUT
PARTICULARLY SUPPORTED TONIGHT
AS THE- THE EIGHTY ONE THIRTY
THREE- THE MEDIC THE CHANGE
THAT THE MEDICAL ASSETS HAVE
AND EXPANSION. OF MEDICARE AL
TO- MORE PERSONS IN CALIFORNIA
SO THAT WE CAN BE EVEN BETTER
CLOSER TO HELP HAUL FROM WORLD
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF- EIGHTY ONE
THIRTY FIVE- THE TOWERS PACKAGE
VERY ROBUST MANY CHANGES THAT
ARE REALLY GOING. TO BE
IMPACTFUL FOR CLIENT- SO LONG
OVERDUE INCREASE IN THE US.
GRANT WHICH IS THEN- I'M MORE
THAN A DECADE IN THE MAKING BUT
FINALLY COMING TO FRUITION THIS
BUDGET WE'RE SO HAPPY TO BE
THERE- AND THEN WE JUST WANT
ALSO KNOWLEDGE THAT THIS BUDGET
REALLY BEGIN I THINK WHAT. ARE
THEY REALLY NEEDED REFORMS IN
THE CHILD SUPPORT ARENA. WE'VE
REALLY GOT TO THINK ABOUT HOW
WE PUT CHILDREN FIRST. HERE IN
THIS IN THE WAY THAT WE ROLL
THIS PROGRAM OUT AND WE'RE VERY
APPRECIATIVE. OF THE STEPS
BEING TAKEN IN THE BUDGET
SPEAKING ALSO SO WITH ALL THAT
WE SUPPORT THESE TWO BILLS AND
WE URGE THE- LEGISLATURE TO
PASS. FOR QUICK. THANK YOU. FOR
BUYING TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY FOUR.
THANK YOU CHAIRWOMAN INNER AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS NICOLE BROWN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
PROGRAM ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING COMMUNITY DAY
STATE THE THINGS FOR READING OR
AFFECT THE FAMILIES AT THE OVER.
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND NEW CHILD
CARE SLOTS. ONE WITH THE COURT
HISTORICAL INVESTMENT IN EIGHTY
ONE THIRTY ONE TO INCREASE THE
RATES FOR OUR CENTRAL CHILDCARE
AND EARLY LEARNING
PROFESSIONALS. PROVIDE THE
NEEDED I THINK THE NETTING TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND EACH
CHILD CARE. FOR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES TO ACCESS. WE ARE
APPRECIATIVE OF THE WAITING OF
PAM IT'S A ONE YEAR BUT ARE
CONCERNED THAT HE COULD HAVE
BEEN WAIT FOR TWO YEARS IN
ACCORDANCE WITH A FLEXIBLE
LANGUAGE. PERMITTED UNDER THE
FEDERAL AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN
AFTER TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WE
WANT TO THANK SENATOR LIFE AND
THE LEADERSHIP OF THE LEFT SIDE
OF WOMEN'S POCKETS FOR MAKING
CHILD CARE A PRIORITY. AND
TAKING ON THE ISSUE OF
REIMBURSEMENT RATE FOR FORM AND
MAKING THAT A REALITY THAT WILL
FINALLY HAPPEN. FINALLY I WANT
TO BRING TO YOUR ATTENTION. OUR
STRONG CONCERNS SURROUNDING THE
LOWER INCOME FAMILIES ACCSSING
THE NEW CHILD CARE SLOTS.
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET BILLS
FUNDING FOR THE STOCK BUT
THERE'S NO FUNDING FOR THE
COMMUNITY AGENCIES AROUND FAT.
CURRENTLY SIXTY EIGHT THOUSAND
CHILD CARE ABOUT DOCTOR FOSTER
FUNDED. IMMUNITY AGENCIES ARE
ACTIVE HEY NOW YOU'RE AN
ENROLLMENT SPECIALIST TO
SUPPORT AFFECT THE FAMILY.
SIXTY EIGHT THOUSAND CHILDCARE
SLOTS. NOT AN ADDITIONAL TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND. THANK YOU AND
YOUR STAFF FOR ALL OF YOUR HARD
WORK WE ASK THAT YOU PLEASE
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
BACK CALIFORNIA'S WORKING
FAMILIES. WHO CAN BUILD BACK
HOPEFULLY THANK YOU. ONE TWO
HUNDRED NINETY. REPORT MANAGER
AND MEMBERS OF ERICA HOFFMAN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
BOARDS ASSOCIATION I'D LIKE TO
SPEAK BRIEFLY ONTO THE MEASURES
BEFORE YOU- WE AREN'T SUPPORTED
MAYBE ONE THIRTY THREE THAT'S
THE HEALTH TRAILER BILL
ESPECIALLY THE PROPOSED THAT
PROVISIONS DEALING WITH THE
CHILDREN AND YOUTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INITIATIVE THIS WILL AT
LEAST START THE PROCESS IN
ORDER TO GET MORE PEOPLE INTO
THE CLASSROOM. IN ORDER TO HELP
OUR STUDENTS CAN PROVIDE MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES THAT ARE TIED
TO YOUR MEDICARE AND YOUR
MANAGED CARE PLANS WE
APPRECIATE. ALL THE WORK THAT'S
BEEN DONE ON THAT I'M ALSO CALL
INTO OF EIGHTY ONE SO THE
BROADBAND MAC AND I JUST
ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH THE
COMMENTS ARE MY I HE GOT TO THE
THIS A MESSAGE IT NEEDED OUR
STUDENTS NEED IT IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT THEY HAVE ACCESS TO
ALL THE EDUCATIONAL. PROGRAMS
THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO. YEAH WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. ONE
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE. MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
FLORIDA MY NAME IS OFTEN TOWARD
DONALD. PRESIDENT OF THE SOCIAL
EQUITY OWNERS AND WORKERS
ASSOCIATION- AWARD TO. THE
SOLUTION- SENATOR MCGUIRE FOR
HIS GREAT COMMENTS ON- EIGHTY
ONE SIXTY SIX I STAND IN
SUPPORT OF THAT AT THIS POINT
AND YOU MANAGE THE INTERNET
SHOULD BE A BASIC HUMAN RIGHT
SO LET'S GET THIS DONE I'M ALSO
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTY
ONE SIXTY- HOWEVER. THE BUDGET
LANGUAGE CONTINUES TO FAIL TO
INCLUDE ANY STATE. DEFINITION
OF SOCIAL EQUITY DESPITE THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE SUBMITTED
DETAILED LANGUAGE TO ADDRESS
THAT PROBLEM. BUT THERE'S
REPEATED REFERENCE IN THE
BUDGET LANGUAGE ABOUT LOCAL
EQUITY PROGRAMS BUT WITHOUT THE
STATE DEFINITIONS THERE IS NO
REAL UNIFORM GUIDANCE.
UNDERSTATE ALL THESE PROGRAMS
ACTUALLY LOOK LIKE THE CURRENT
LANGUAGE. INDICATES THAT THE
STATE IS NOT REALLY SERIOUS
ABOUT HOLDING A LARGE OPERATORS
AT BAY. THE RESTRICTION A LARGE
CULTIVATORS CONTAINS A LOOPHOLE
THAT YOU CAN DRIVE A TRUCK
THROUGH. THE LAW ALL THE LARGE
CULTIVATED HAVE TO DO TO AVOID
THE STATE RESTRICTIONS IS
CERTAIN THAT THEY JUST DON'T
HAVE A LARGE CONTIGUOUS PARCEL
THAT EXCEEDS THE LIMITATION.
UNLIMITED. NUMBER OF SMALL
APARTMENTS ARE OKAY. THE PLATE
BUNDLE. ON THE SOCIAL. WHAT
I'LL GET AN OBSTACLES WHAT ARE
PATHWAYS INTO PROVISIONAL
LICENSE OR- I THINK PART THAT
IN ACCESS TO THE ALLOTTED STATE
FUNDING HAD CONTINUOUSLY BEEN
DELAYED YEAR AFTER YEAR IT IS
IMPERATIVE TO EXPAND UNDER
PROVISIONAL LICENSES AT LEAST A
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE ALSO SWIFTLY
LIKE. WE WANT THE SAME
EXPEDITED PATHWAY THAT BORDERS
THE ARE NON SOCIAL EQUITY
APPLICANT BROTHERS AND SISTERS
OVER THE PAST FOUR YEARS. IT IS
OUR TIME IT IS OUR DUTY RIGHT
NOW TO GET ON THE RIGHT SIDE OF
HISTORY AND PRIORITIZE SOCIAL
EQUITY AND NOT SYMBOLICALLY BUT
IN REALITY IT WOULD YOU DO IT
AND IT'S VERY VERY TRAILER BILL
RIGHT NOW. I APPRECIATE ALL YOU
OFFER YOUR HARD WORK AND
DEDICATION TO THE PEOPLE MY
NAME IS ALFRED ON BEHALF OF THE
SOCIAL EQUITY. OWNERS THE
WORKERS ASSOCIATION THANK.
THANK YOU. LINE. TWO HUNDRED
FORTY SEVEN. YES CHAIRWOMAN
SKINNER AND NUMBER- MY- I'M
ALSO A MEMBER OF THE OWNERS AND
WORKERS ASSOCIATION. AND I
WANTED TO- A LOT AND MY CALM AT
THE END WITH THE LAST- SPEAKER.
AND HAVING THE STATE LANGUAGE.
CHANGE TO ACTUALLY FIND THE
DEFINITION OF SOCIAL EQUITY.
BECAUSE IT'S NOT REALLY BE
BUYING. REPEATED- WHO DOES TALK
OF LOCAL EQUITY PROGRAM BUT
WITHOUT THE STATE DEFINITION
THERE'S NO UNIFORM GUIDANCE
FROM THE STATE. SO WE JUST HOPE
THAT YOU GUYS CHANGED THE
LANGUAGE. AND MOVE THAT
FORWARD. I ALSO WANT TO SAY
BASICALLY ABOUT WHAT HE SAID
ABOUT- THE- OPPORTUNITY THAT
YOU'RE ALLOWING- THE- CURRENT-
THE OPERATOR HE DIDN'T
CULTIVATION TO USE THAT
LOOPHOLE TO ACTUALLY GET
AROUND- THE STATE RESTRICTIONS
SO I WOULD HOPE YOU WOULD
CHANGE AND LOOK AT THAT ALSO WE
WANT TO PLOT THE STAFF AND
EVERYTHING THAT YOU'RE DOING I
WANTED TO- APPLAUD SENATOR
MCGUIRE AND THEY WERE A PULL
BEHIND YOU ALTHOUGH IN ONE
FIFTY SIX. IT SHOULD BE- A
PRIORITY FOR EVERYBODY OFF OF.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU. LINE. TWO HUNDRED NINETY
THREE. GOOD EVENING CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBER MOLECULAR
MERRILL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS
THREE IN THE BUDGET TRAILER
BILL BEING VOTED ON TODAY
EIGHTY ONE THIRTY THREE ON THE
SIGNAL QUALITY IT WOULD BE ONE
FORTY ON HOUSING AND IF YOU
WANT TO KEEP THAT FROM
BROADBAND. ONLY FAIRLY BROAD.
IN ONE OF THE KEY LEGAL
CORPORATE ALLOWS THE PUBLIC
NEAT ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
AND PUBLIC HEALTH NEEDS
PARTICULARLY FOR LOW INCOME
RESIDENTS THE COMEDIAN COLOR
AND YOU'RE AFTER YEAR WE
CONTINUE CONFIGURED AFTER SHE
GOT A CONSTITUTIONAL
ENVIRONMENT A LOT THE CREEPY
AND IT ALSO HIGHLIGHTS THAT YOU
MUST CAREFULLY ANALYZE AND
REDUCE THE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT
PROJECT MAY BRING IN ORDER TO
PROTECT THE MOST VULNERABLE
RESIDENTS EIGHT WE WERE
EXTREMELY SUSCEPTIBLE TO AMIRI
OUT OF PUBLIC HEALTH THREAT. TO
CHANGE THE TYPICAL EXTENSION
SHOULD BE DEBATED A PUBLICLY
ACCEPTABLE QUALITY DISCUSSION.
THROUGH THE FULL LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. IT'S OFFICIAL HI FOR
THE TO AND TRANCE WITH THE-
EACH OF THE TRAILER BILL PRESS
AN ISSUES A DRAFT SOCIAL. AND
RACIAL INEQUALITY IN CALIFORNIA
AND IF THEY NEED TO CONFIRM
THAT IT'S NOT LOCKED. BUT WE
CANNOT GO WITHOUT STATING FOR
THE RECORD THAT HE'LL BE IN A
NUMBER OF ENVIRONMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE NUMBER OF FRAUD HE
GOT A PENSION INCLUDED IN
BUDGET TRAILER. FOR JUST EIGHTY
ONE THIRTY THREE EIGHTY ONE
FORTY AND EIGHTY ONE FIFTY SIX
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE COMMENTS. THANK YOU.
LINE TWO HUNDRED NINETY FIVE.
GOOD EVENING ANDREA SAN MIGUEL
ON BEHALF OF PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA
BERKELEY ONE Q. EXPRESS OUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR SOME LEGAL
ONE THIRTY THREE- MANY HAD TO
MANY PROVISIONS- TO GET A NEW
MARINE- BUT I WILL JUST SAY WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT
COMMITTEE CHAIR- AND STAFF AND
MEMBERS FOR. ALL OF THE
DIALOGUE AND SUPPORT THROUGHOUT
OUR CONVERSATION ABOUT CONSOLE
HELP FLEXIBILITY IS AND
INSURING THEIR CONTINUED ACCESS
FOR MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES YOU
TELEHEALTH AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING. TO WORK WITH
EVERYONE ON THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. BY. TWO
HUNDRED NINETY TWO. GOOD DAY
MADAM CARE MY NAME IS VICKY I'M
THE CO FOUNDER AND THE FIRST
AFRICAN AMERICAN ASIAN AND
FOUNDING MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS EQUITY IF
THERE IS AN- AFRICAN AMERICAN
WOMAN WE COULD HAVE BEEN ON AND
OFF THE ANGELUS. AND I'M HERE
TODAY. BECAUSE I'M NOT LOOKING
AT ONE. I THINK THE VERIFY
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY.
STATEMENT MAKE A REAL
COMMITMENT TO EQUITY. BUT THE
EQUITY TO GIVE THOSE WHO HAVE
BEEN AT. IT GIVE US AN
ADVANTAGE THE COMPANY MARKET
TIME IT'S NOT LIKE ANYTHING
AND- BE FOR EQUITY WE
APPRECIATE THE EXTRA YEAR. I
DON'T BELIEVE YOU UNDERSTAND
OUR PLEASE AT THE END OF YOUR
HEART ON INCOMING CALLS AT THE
ASK YOU FOR THAT I'LL BE IN THE.
BOOK AND I CAN'T WAIT TO
PROVISIONALLY. NOW ONLY WHAT WE-
WHAT HAVE TO FACE OUT ASKED TO
CAPITAL- MOVING GOVERNMENT IN
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES. EVERY
YEAR THAT WE CAN WAIT TO GET MY-
IT. EXPANDED NOT LIKE NOTHING
THAT THE TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
ALTHOUGH I COULD BE LIKE BEHIND
NOT COMPENSATION. YOU WANT THE
THINGS WHICH I DO HAVE OPENING
OUR DOORS AT. FORTY NINE HOLES.
IN AT FOUR YEARS. AT THE- AND
IT IS NOT GOING TO. GOOD AS IT
USED TO WORK. AT THE IN THE
RANKINGS. GET YOUR KICKS CALLS
NOTHING ELSE. EIGHT F. ONE HAVE
A DEFINED HAVE DEFINITION WHAT
WILL SEPARATE YOU FROM THE. I
AM A GREAT WE ARE IN OF YOUR
GUY. AND SO THANK YOU LET ME
ASK THE POLICE TO TRACK
AMERICAN IN THE WHICH- HAVE A
GREAT DAY. TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU HELLO MADAM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I WANTED TO
GET BACK OFF OR WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE HERE MY NAME IS
CHARLES LARKIN I'M ALSO A BOARD
MEMBER WITH THE SOCIAL EQUITY
HOLDERS AND WORKERS
ASSOCIATION- HI TO AGREE WITH
THEM OR WIRE ON THE- STRING
ABOUT ONE FIFTY SIX. WITH THE
INTERNET YOU KNOW MYDAD LIVES
IN COMPTON CALIFORNIA AND IF
THE INTERNET IS VERY BAD BUT
THEN WHEN I CALL HOME ABOUT
FIVE MILES. WEST OF PERFECT
SERVICE. YOU KNOW THAT. THEY
CAN. YOU KNOW AND I HOPE IT
REALLY- RECOMMENDED NEVER
HAPPENED TO ME IN THE- HE'LL-
YOU NOT ONLY. SENIOR ABOUT FOUR
YOU THINK IT'S A NEED WHILE LOW
INCOME NEIGHBORHOODS THEY NEED
INTERNET ACCESS FOR CLASSROOM
OR OPERATIVE STUDIES AND I HOPE
THAT WORKS FOR THEM AND WE NEED
TO GET THAT DONE. ALSO. WANTED
TO BECOME AN EIGHTY ONE SIX.
YOU KNOW THE DEFINITION OF
SOCIAL EQUITY A VERY IMPORTANT.
PART OF IT MEANS. AND I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU KNOW IT CAN
BE REMEMBERED YEAH WE'RE
SUPPORT IN THE EVENING IN THE
AMENDMENT FOR WE ARE YOU.
PLEASE INCLUDE THAT DEFINITION
YOU KNOW THE DEFINITION OF
PROPER LANGUAGE IN THE BILL.
BUT WHAT ABOUT THE DEFINITION
THERE'S REALLY NO UNIFORM
GUIDANCE ON WHAT THE PROGRAM
LOOK LIKE. YOU KNOW- ANOTHER
THING. I'VE BEEN A SUBJECT OF
AFRICAN AND WERE LOCKED IN
PROFIT OF STAMPING YOU DON'T
HOLD FOR YEARS I'VE ALSO WORKED
HUNDREDS TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS OF ANYTHING IS PROPER
FINALLY MADE IT TO THE STATE.
AND WE EXPANDED IT IMPERATIVE
RIGHT NOW TWO WEEKS INTO
PROFESSIONAL LIFE UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE ALSO TRACK WHEN HE
FIGHTS. YOU WANT THE SAME.
EXPEDITED PATHWAY ACCORDING TO
EVERYONE I'VE GONE BEFORE US
WHICH OF THE NON CONTRACTED
AFRICAN PHOTOGRAPH. MY WIFE
REPUBLICAN INVOLVEMENT WITH
AND- WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND YOUR HARD WORK THROUGH THE
WIND WE THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING. THANK YOU AND
CHARLES WALKER FOR. A LINE OF
THREE HUNDRED FOUR. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS RANDY MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF CMG KHALIFA- WE REGRETTABLY
REMAIN OPPOSED TO AV SP ONE
SIXTY THE CANNABIS TRAILER BILL
WE REMAIN DEEPLY TROUBLED THAT
THE BILL MAINTAINS THE
EXCESSIVELY COMPRESSED TIME
FRAME FOR- CANNABIS CULTIVATORS
OVER A SINGLE ACRE TO
TRANSITION FROM A PROVISIONAL
LICENSE TO AN ANNUAL LICENSE
LET ME SHARE WITH YOU ONE OF
THE REASONS WHY WE ARE
SKEPTICAL THAT THAT COMPRESSED
TIME FRAME WILL BE ENOUGH TIME.
WHEN WE REACHED OUT TO OUR CITY
JUST LAST WEEK TO ASK THEM
ABOUT THEIR ABILITY TO. HELP US
GET TO SEEK A COMPLAINT THEY
SAID THAT THEY WERE BEGINNING
TO PUT A PLAN TOGETHER WITH
THEIR PLANNING DEPARTMENT AND
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
UNFORTUNATELY THEY SAID THE
SAME THING TO US SIX MONTHS AGO
WHICH DOES NOT GIVE US A LOT OF
CALM CONFIDENCE. THAT LOCAL
STATE GOVERNMENTS STRUGGLE TO
TRANSITION THOUSANDS OF THESE-
LICENSES TO ANNUAL LICENSES
WITHIN A YEAR OR TWO NUMEROUS
RESPONSIBLE CULTIVATORS WHO'VE
BEEN PLAYING BY THE RULES- WILL
LOSE THEIR LICENSES THROUGH NO
FAULT OF THEIR OWN CAUSING A
LOSS OF TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN CULTIVATION TAX
GENERATION LOSS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS IN LOCAL TAXES LOSS OF
THOUSANDS OF JOBS. IN THE LOSS
OF MILLIONS OF POUNDS OF
BIOMASS WITH DELIRIOUS- THE
DELETERIOUS IMPACTS ON THE
DOWNSTREAM RETAILERS AND
MANUFACTURERS FOR THOSE REASONS
WE ENCOURAGE YOU TO OPPOSE. AB
ONE SIXTY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THE LINE. TO HUNDRED EIGHTY
FIVE. GOOD EVENING TERM MEMBERS
BRENNAN DAWSON WITH HERE
CALIFORNIA YOUR LINE UP COMES
WITH THOSE MADE OF FROM- COPD
EARLIER- WE EXPRESSED CONCERNS
WITH THE PROG TO DETENTION POND
AND- TRYING TO BUILD A B. ONE
THIRTY THREE EIGHTY ONE FOR YOU
MAYBE ONE FIFTY SIX AM WHERE
ACTUALLY ADD THE FOURTH ONE AND
EIGHTY ONE FORTY EIGHT RELATED
TO DROUGHT MEASURES- THE MOTIVE
BEHIND THE BILLS SUCH AS THE
NEED TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS
HOMELESSNESS AND HOUSING
PRICES. PROVIDING EQUITABLE
BROADBAND ACCESS TO COMMUNITY
TO MITIGATING SEVERE DROUGHT
IMPACTING THE STATE CURRENTLY
BUT THE INCLUSION OF THE SECRET
EXEMPTIONS MAKE THE CALLS ARE
NECESSARY THEN ONLY PERPETUATE
THE FALSE NARRATIVE THAT
BECAUSE OKAY IS AN IMPEDIMENT
TO PROVIDING PUBLIC SERVICES SO
WE LOOK FORWARD TO SPEAKING
WITH YOU. ABOUT THESE AND THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. BLINDED THREE
HUNDRED. CHAIRWOMAN AND MEMBERS
MARK SMITH BEHALF OF THE ORIGIN
COUNSEL REPRESENTING SIX
HUNDRED LICENSED AND ANCILLARY
CANNABIS BUSINESS NUMBERS
OPERATING THE BUSINESS STORE
CANNABIS FARMING REGIONS OF
CALIFORNIA WE WANT TO
APPRECIATE A CONSIDERABLE
AMOUNT OF WORK THAT WENT INTO
AV SP ONE SIXTY WE ARE
EXTREMELY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
TIMELINE EXTENSION FOR THE
LAUNCH OF THE CANNABIS
APPELLATIONS PROGRAM. WE
BELIEVE THIS ADDITIONAL TIME
WILL HELP INSURE A SUCCESSFUL
ROLLOUT OF THIS PRECEDENT
SETTING PROGRAM WITH RESPECT TO
PROVISIONAL LICENSING YOU
APPRECIATE AND SUPPORT THE
REVISIONS THAT ENSURE
COMPLIANCE BENCHMARKS ARE
BROADLY APPLICABLE TO ALL
JURISDICTIONAL APPROACHES TO
SEEK FOR COMPLIANCE HOWEVER WE
DO HAVE SOME GREAT CONCERNS AT
THE TIME LINE FOR THE U.
COMPLIANCE BENCHMARKS CAN HE BE
UNREALISTIC. PROVISIONAL
LICENSEES ARE STATUTORILY
DENIED THE RIGHT OF APPEAL IN
UNDER THIS MEASURE FACING
GREATLY INCREASED RISK OF
LICENSING INTERRUPTION OR LOSS
YOU KNOW ALL OF THEIR OWN I
WOULD REQUEST THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CLOSELY TRACK
PROGRESS ON THE IMPLEMENTATION.
OF THESE COMPLIANCE BENCHMARKS.
PREEMPTED AND- TO ENSURE THAT
LIFE. THAT ARE ACTIVELY AND
DILIGENTLY PURSUING THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR ANNUAL
LICENSES ARE PROTECTED. IN
CLOSING OUR ORGANIZATION
CONTINUES TO ADVOCATE FOR A
COMPREHENSIVE ASSESSMENT OF THE
STATE LICENSING FRAMEWORK-
PURSUE STRUCTURAL REFORMS THAT
WOULD LOWER BARRIERS TO ENTRY
FOR ASPIRING SMALL BUSINESS.
AND SMALL ARMS SEEKING
LICENSURE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT
TODAY. THANK YOU. ONE THREE
HUNDRED THANK. GOOD EVENING
REBECCA BACK AND ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ADVANCED
BIOFUELS ALLIANCE AND WE OPPOSE
THE INCLUSION OF RENEWABLE
FUELS AND OIL SPILL PREVENTION
IN. FIVE IN EIGHTY ONE FORTY
FIFTY WILL INCREASE THE PRICE
OF RENEWABLE FUELS WHEN WE
SHOULD BE PROMOTING THE USE OF
THEM RENEWABLE FUELS ARE VITAL
TO THE STATE'S CARBON
NEUTRALITY GOALS AND SHOULD BE
SUBJECT TO A HISTORICALLY
PATROLLING ONLY FEET WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
FURTHER ON THAT THANK YOU AND
HAVE A GOOD EVENING THANK YOU.
BY. TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THREE.
GOOD AFTERNOON TRACY RYAN ON
BEHALF OF THE WORLD. CALIFORNIA
THE POINT OF EIGHTY ONE FORTY
AND EIGHTY ONE FIVE SIX.
BEGINNING WITH ONE ONE FIVE SIX
YEARS PERFORMANCE OF THE
PROVISION FOR PROMOTING ALL
STATE WIDE HERE ON MY OWN. WELL
THE CHANGES TO THE COMPANY AND
THEY ARE PERFECTLY FINE THE
BAHRAIN UNDERSTAND AREAS OF
BOTH WITHOUT ACCESS TO TWENTY
FIVE THREE. EIGHTY ONE PROJECT
ALSO PRIORITIZES FUNDING FOR
THOSE AREAS WHAT LESSONS ONE
FINALLY WE APPRECIATE THE
INNOVATIVE PROVISIONS
APPLICABLE LAWS WE VERIFIED
THAT WILL ALLOW PRIVATE PUBLIC
PARTNERSHIPS TO PROVIDE
BROADBAND PROJECT IN OUR RURAL.
AND URBAN AREAS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINE TWO HUNDRED.
LIFE TO HER. SEVENTY SHARE
MEMBERS SO THEY'LL GO OUT ON
BEHALF OF THE MAYOR OF OAKLAND
WOULD BE SHOCKED FOUR SIX PRESS
ACCREDITED APPRECIATION FOR A
DIRECT ALLOCATION OF WHAT WILL
ALMOST ALWAYS THAT MAYBE AT ONE
FORTY. THANK YOU CENTER SCANNER.
CAN MATCH THE APPLE YOU ALL
WORK ON THIS ISSUE. TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY ONE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THIS IS ERIC LAWYER SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIPHATE
RETIREMENT SAVINGS FOR THE
BOARD SPORTS PROVISIONS OF AB
ONE THIRTY THREE THAT WOULD
REMOVE THE ASSET TESTER MEDICO
AND THAT WOULD REMOVE AN
INCENTIVE FOR CALIFORNIANS TO
SACRIFICE RETIREMENT SECURITY
FOR HEALTHCARE THE BORDERS THAT
RESPECTFULLY. LISTEN ANOTHER
ASPECT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO- HI
MARVIN CAN NOW BE HAPPY BUT IF
YOU ASK THE TEAM AT CALIFORNIA
WANTED THANK GOD INTERMENT WIRE
FOR ALL THE DEATH RATE IN THE
BROADBAND BILL I LOOK UP AT
THE- CAMPESINO STARRED FOR THE
FARM WORKERS IN HARD TO REACH
AREA. I DID A LOT OF PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN GONE WE THANK YOU FOR
BEING A CHAMPION FOR THOSE FARM
WORKERS AND FOR THOSE THAT HAVE
OFTEN BEEN LEFT BEHIND ALSO
I'LL BE HAPPY THAT UNITED KIND
OF IT DIDN'T TEACH IN THE
SUPPORT EIGHTY F. B. ONE SIX
THE CABBAGE PATCH TRADER BILL I
WOULD LIKE TO CLEAN UP LANGUAGE
IN THE NEAR FUTURE SO THEY
KINDA LIKE THESE ARE ABLE TO.
RELOCATE ADEN CIRCUMSTANCES
THAT ARE BEYOND OUR CONTROL
SUCH AS BEING ASKED TO INDICATE
BY LANDLORD I WE THINK THAT THE
CURRENT. REQUIREMENT VERY
EXTREME VERY DIFFICULT TO MEET
AND WILL SUPPORT A LOT OF OUR
LIFE YOU COULD POTENTIALLY LOSE
THEIR LICENSE AND WE ALSO ASK
FOR AN EXTENSION FOR EVERYONE
ON PROVISIONAL FOR A YEAR- WE
HAVE SMALL BUSINESS FAMILY
OWNED BUSINESS THAT ALSO WOULD
BENEFIT FROM THE EXPANSION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALL THE
WORK. THANK YOU. WHAT LINE
HUNDRED THREE. GOOD EVENING
CAMP SHELBY ON OF WILDLIFE AND
SUPPORT AT EIGHTY ONE SIXTY THE
CANADA TRADE REBEL WE
APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS MADE BY
THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE AND OTHER INTEREST
GROUPS TO COME TO A REASONABLE
RESOLUTION TO EXTEND THE
PROVISIONAL LICENSE PROGRAM
WHILE ENSURING THAT WE'RE
MAKING PROGRESS TO HEAR KIDS
BARBARA PROTECTION. ON THE
OTHER DEFENDERS IN THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY
ALSO ONE OF THE FOURTEEN CREEK
TO THE CABAL OF PEACH AND
INCLUSION OF RENEWABLE FUEL THE
PARTNER BEING EIGHTY ONE FORTY
EIGHT TO ADDRESS THE STRUCTURAL
IMBALANCE IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH WILDLIFE. WILL FILL IN THE
STREET HE FOUND. HIMSELF
WHETHER OIL OR RENEWABLE FUELS
HAVE A FIREMAN INTACT. AND
SHOULD BE SUBJECT TO THE C.
WITHOUT BEING SAID IF YOU SURE
CAN. RAISED ABOUT THE PROTOCOLS
AND TRAINING FOR THE
EXPENDITURE OF THE FACT THAT
THE FIVE HUNDRED BILLION DOLLAR
BUYER MONEY IN THE BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR. ABOUT BILL BASICALLY
SAID THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WILL DECIDE WHEN WHERE AND FOR
WHAT THAT FUNDING WILL BE
EXTENDED FOR AND THEN REPORT.
BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE IT'S
OUR HOPE THAT THEY'LL BE
ADDITIONAL TRAILER BILL LATER
THIS SESSION. WILL PROVIDE
GREATER CLARITY AND DIRECTION
FOR THE EXPENDITURE OF THOSE
FUNDS. AND FINALLY DEPENDENCY
IMPACTS WRONGLY OBJECT.
EQUITIES OPTIONS IN EIGHTY ONE
THIRTY THREE ONE FORTY. ONE
FORTY EIGHT. AND EVEN MORE SO
IN EIGHTY ONE. SIX IN WHICH
THERE'S A SWEEPING SEQUENCE
ACTION. BUT THE THREE POINT
SEVEN FIVE BILLION BROADBAND
PROJECT- WE OF COURSE SUPPORT
BROADBAND BUT WE DO NOT BELIEVE
THAT THERE SHOULD BE FREQUENT
SECTION. WOULD ALIGN OUR
CONTACT WITH THOSE MADE BY
MELISSA ROMERO IT FEELS EASY
AND BRANDON DAWKINS. WITH- CLUB
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THE LINE.
THREE HUNDRED EIGHT. GOOD
EVENING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
GOTCHA TODAY ON BEHALF OF
COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF
AMERICA DISTRICT NINE- CW A
LOOKS FORWARD TO IMPROVING THE
OVERALL BROADBAND PROPOSAL TO
ENSURE CALIFORNIA WORKERS ARE
UTILIZED ESPECIALLY THOSE WITH
BROADBAND EXPERIENCE AND HIGH
LABOR STANDARDS ARE ADOPTED
THANK YOU. BY. TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON DANA
REVERSE WITH THE WORLD POCKETS
OF THE CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC
PARTY- FIRST OF ALL I'D LIKE TO
THANK AND- EXPRESS MY
ADMIRATION FOR SENATOR
MCGUIRE'S REMARKS IN FAVOR OF
ONE FIFTY SIX AND WE WOULD ADD
OUR SUPPORT OUR STRONG SUPPORT
TO THAT BILL AND- THE NEEDS OF
THE WORLD COUNTIES. FOR
BROADBAND THANK YOU. THE LINE
IS. THREE HUNDRED TWELVE. GOOD
EVENING AND HE FELL ON BEHALF
OF THAT VALUE CALIFORNIA WE
WANT TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY ONE SIXTY
REGARDING THE DEPARTMENT'S
CANISTERS CAN'T CONTROL- WE
APPRECIATE AND SUPPORT THE
STATE CONTINUED WORK INCREASED
ENFORCEMENT ON REQUIREMENTS FOR
WORKER PROTECTIONS THE CREATION
OF A PATHWAY FOR EQUITY
APPLICANTS FIFTEEN
ENVIRONMENTAL COMPLIANCE. AND
FOR ADDING CLARITY AND HEALTH
AND PUBLIC SAFETY PROTECTIONS
ON THE PROVISIONS RELATED TO
TRADE SAMPLE HOWEVER WE DO
AGREE WITH THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS COMMENT THAT IT STATES
THAT MISSION OF SOCIAL EQUITY
IS NECESSARY IN THE NEAR FUTURE
TO ENSURE CONTINUED. PROGRESS
IN THE FIELD THANK YOU. TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY SIX. ANYTHING MY
NAME IS CRIMINAL LIABILITY
CHILD LACHLAN THERE ARE COMMON
BETWEEN TWO EIGHTY ONE EIGHTY
ONE WE WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
LEGISLATURE FOR POTENTIAL ON
THAT CHILD CARE WITH THE
INCREASE CALCULATE RATES
ACTUALLY. THIS IS A HISTORIC
YEAR WE LOOK FORWARD. TO SEEING
MORE DETAILS ABOUT THEM. WE ARE
VERY. OF THE WEAVER FAMILY
FEATURE ONE YEAR WE ARE
DISAPPOINTED THAT THEY ARE NOT
WAIT FOR A SECOND HERE OR THAT
THERE IS NOT A GLOBAL FAMILY
DETACHABLE THAT CAPPED THE THAT
CAN PRESENT A FAMILY INCOME.
SPECIALLY GIVEN PREVIOUS
CONFESSION AND FEDERAL LOAN
BONDS. ADDITIONALLY WE LOOK
FORWARD TO DETAILED LANGUAGE
REGARDING THE DISTRIBUTION OF
THE CHILDCARE EXPLANATION GOT.
SHOT YOUR PROVIDERS WITH
SUPPLEMENTAL INFORMATION
COLLECTION CALENDAR LANGUAGE IN
SECTION FORTY SIX TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY AND TWO HUNDRED SIXTY
FIVE OF THEM. FINALLY WE LOOK
FORWARD TO MORE DETAILS ON THE
NUMBER OF CHILD CARE ALTERNATE
PAYMENT THOUGHT AND HOW THE.
AMOUNT TO BE ALLOCATED THANK
YOU. LIED TO HUNDRED NINETY
SEVEN. HELLO MY NAME IS ANDREA
AND HER- I AM IN THE
LEGISLATIVE AND POLICY DIRECTOR
AT CLEAN WATER ACTION AND WE
ARE ONE OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS THAT YOU'VE HEARD
FROM SOME OF OUR COLLEAGUES ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT SOME OF THE C.
CORE EXEMPTIONS THAT ARE
SHOWING UP IN 813-314-0150 SIX
POINT FORTY EIGHT. I'M ONE OF
THE PEOPLE OTHERS HAVE SAID BUT
I WILL AND THAT IT DOESN'T SEEM
TO MAKE SENSE TO THAT WELL. WE
UNDERSTAND THAT MANY OF THE
THINGS IN THESE BUDGET BILLS
THE LEGISLATURE IS TRYING TO DO
REALLY GOOD THINGS FOR
COMMUNITIES. BUT IT DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE TO OUR TO DO THOSE
THINGS IN WAYS THAT ACTUALLY
PUT THEM IN HARM'S WAY. AND
ALSO LEAVE THOSE VERY
COMMUNITIES OUT OF THE
DISCUSSION. OF HOW THESE
PROGRAMS THAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT-OR THE SERVICES ARE
GOING TO BE IMPLEMENTED. AND
FOR THAT REASON WE WOULD URGE
YOU TO BE VERY CAREFUL WE HEAR
ALL SORTS OF EXCUSES ABOUT.
COMMUNITY NEEDS EMERGENCIES WE
HEAR THAT EVERY YEAR. THERE IS
A REASON BECAUSE A LOT OF THE
CALIFORNIA LAND THERE'S A
REASON WHY THIS WAS PUT INTO
PLACE TO ACTUALLY PREVENT HARM
TO COMMUNITIES. AND WE WOULD
HOPE THAT. THESE EXEMPTIONS
WOULD NOT MOVE FORWARD AS PART
OF. THE PACKAGE. THANK YOU.
LINE. THREE HUNDRED FOURTEEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON OR EVENING CAN
YOU HEAR ME. WE CAN HEAR YOU.
SH HI THERE MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS JOHN
GOLDFINGER AND I AM THE CEO OF
THE HERS IN LOS ANGELES WHICH
YOU MAY RECOGNIZE AS
CALIFORNIA'S FIRST- MOBILE
COMPREHENSION AND LARGEST
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS AND
SUICIDE PREVENTION HOTLINE WE
ARE WHERE YOU MAY KNOW I WILL
BE CALM HAT NINE EIGHT EIGHT.
LINE WHICH SOME FOLKS THINK IS
AN ALTERNATIVE NINE ONE ONE-
BUT REALLY I REMIND THEM IN THE
AMBULANCE ONLY OVER THE PHONE
AND FEDERAL LAW REQUIRES US TO
BE READY FOR THOSE CALLS IN
JULY TWENTY TWENTY TWO FOR
WHICH THE HEARST LEAD
CALIFORNIA THIRTEEN STATEWIDE
PRACTICE LINES IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY PLANNING IMPLEMENTATION
AND SCALING ON BEHALF OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. AND YEAH AS A
PEDIATRICIAN AND CHILD AND
FAMILY TRAUMA RESEARCHER WHO
INVITED THE OFFICE OF THE
SURGEON GENERAL AND THE H. YET
COME ON OTHERS I AM COMPELLED
TO HIGHLIGHT GLARING CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE GAP TO MEET THE
DEMAND CHILDREN AND YOUTH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH IN THE
COUNTRY BIJAN IN TRAILER REAL
LANGUAGE WHILE WE ARE TRYING TO
FIND THE CALIFORNIA WE'RE
EXCITED TO SEE A STRONG
INVESTMENT IN THE CHILDREN YOUR
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH INITIATIVE.
FOR INNOVATION AND PREVENTION
WHERE ALL CHILDREN AND YOUTH
ARE SCREENED AND SUPPORTED FOR
EMERGING NEEDS WE RECOGNIZE
THAT SUICIDE AND OVERDOSES ARE
ALARMINGLY AMONG THOSE EMERGING
NEEDS WITH EXPONENTIAL GAPS IN
CHILDREN- AND YET NOTHING
MENTIONED ABOUT THAT SORT OF
THE OPPOSITE SIDE PREVENTION WE
WERE THRILLED TO SEE THE
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CONTINUUM
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENT
WHAT'S THE PROBLEM NO MENTION
OF NINETY EIGHT PRICES CLIMBED
IN EITHER OF THESE INITIATIVES.
ALONGSIDE GLOBAL RESPONSE AND
THE. YOUR ACCOUNT INTACT.
PLATFORM THAT BEING. BY NINETY
EIGHT YEAH. I THINK THE SUICIDE
LIFELINE IS FEDERAL BUT IT HAS
NOT. FOR ME TO BE HERE HEALTH
PROVIDER WEB THERE TO FOUR
SEVEN ON THE FRONT OF MY
INCLUDING CALLS CAN'T IN
ENGLISH AND MANY OTHER
LANGUAGES FOR CALIFORNIA
CITIZEN OVER 75% OF THE JACKSON
TAX WE RECEIVED ON THE CRISIS
LINE FAR FROM YOU UNDER THE AGE
OF TWENTY FIVE. ADDITIONALLY
WITH THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
NINETY EIGHT NEXT YEAR
INCLUDING TEXT MESSAGE WE KNOW
THE VOLUME OF CALLS AND TEXTS
YOU RECEIVE WILL INCREASE BY AS
MUCH AS TRIPLE OVERNIGHT HER
NATIONAL PROCRASTINATE AND YET
CURRENTLY THERE IS NO- IDENTIFY
FUNDING SOURCES IN THIS BUDGET.
INCREASE OUR CAPACITY TO
STABILIZE IF YOU COULD BEGIN TO
WRAP UP AND YOU COULD. IF YOU
COULD BEGIN TO WRAP UP PLEASE.
YEAH SO BE. WE'RE TALK ABOUT
MILLION CAL. FOR DOM USED TO
WOULD BE DIVERTED AWAY FROM
CALIFORNIA CENTERS WHICH ARE
RECOGNIZED AS THE BEST IN THE
NATION AND THEREFORE WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT YOU
CONSIDER EDITS INCLUDING THE
LINES TWENTY EIGHTEEN. EIGHTY
ONE THIRTY THREE TO INCLUDE AT
LEAST CALIFORNIA'S CRISIS LINE
ALONGSIDE YOUR INVESTMENTS IN
MOBILE CRISIS RESTRUCTURE
SIMPLY ADD THE WORD CRISIS
LINE. THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CONTINUUM INFRASTRUCTURE
PROGRAM AND THAT WOULD HELP.
SUPPORT THE SEARCH THANK YOU. A
LINE OF. THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY.
FIVE THREE HUNDRED EIGHTEEN
YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
MA'AM CHERRY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT SHOUTS WHEN
ROBBIE HAPPEN EACH ANSWER AT
THE AUDUBON CALIFORNIA TRYING.
TO MODERATOR DID WE LOSE THAT
CALL OR- I WILL SHOW THEM IT
CONNECTED LIFE THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN ARE YOU STILL THERE
DID YOU TURN DO YOU HAVE
YOURSELF ON MUTE. YOU KNOW I
HEAR HE'S ALRIGHT EVERY. WEEK
WE CAN HEAR YOU NOW. PLEASE
READ AT. THANK YOU MA'AM SHARED
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
WITHOUT MEMBER ON BEHALF OF
NATURE CONSERVANCY AUDUBON
CALIFORNIA TROUT UNLIMITED IN
CALIFORNIA COULD PROTECTION
THAT WORK IMPORTED EIGHTY ONE
SIXTY ONE VOTERS APPROVED
PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN THEY DID CLEAR
INTENT THAT LIKE YOU COULD BE
REQUIRED TO FOLLOW STRICT
ENVIRONMENTAL- BUT THEY CAN. BE
ENTERED AS A CONDITION MAKING
OUR LIFE AND WE HAVE BEEN
SIGNIFICANT CONCERN. WITH THE
CONTINUED EXTENSION OF THE
PROVISIONAL LICENSE PROGRAM AT
TWENTY TWENTY SIX. TEN YEARS
AFTER THE PROP THAT HAPPENS
ACROSS THE KEYBOARD HOWEVER WE
ARE SUPPORTING THE INCLUSION OF
THESE IMPORTANT MILE MARKERS TO
DEMONSTRATE COMPLIANCE WITH THE
QUOTE. IN OTHER ENVIRONMENTAL
PROVISIONS INCLUDING THE
LINCOLN STREET AN ATERATION
AGREEMENT. PROVISIONS ARE
CRITICAL TO THE LINE VOTERS
INTEND TO TOPPING GOT THE KEY
FOR. WELCOME HAPPY TO SEE THE
INTENT LANGUAGE TO BE THE FINAL
EXTENSION- I THINK I SPEAK FOR
MANY. WHEN I SAY WE DON'T WANT
HIM BACK A COUPLE YEARS WE
HOUSE WITH YOU AGAIN. AND
FINALLY WERE SUPPORTED BY A
HUNDRED MILLION BUT ALCANTARA
GOVERNMENT HELP EXPEDITE
BARNALA RUBIO. THREE THREE
HUNDRED THE COURT EIGHTY ONE
SIXTY EIGHTY AND THAT YOU WANT
TO CAN- DRIVE. OUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. YOUR LINE IS THREE
SEVENTEEN. GOOD EVENING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AMY HINES
SHAIKH REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LAND TRUST
NETWORK AND STRONG SUPPORT AT
EIGHTY ONE FORTY THE HOUSING
BATTLE I'VE ACTUALLY RECORDING
THE VISIONARY PROGRAM OF THE
FORECLOSURE INTERVENTION
HOUSING PRESERVATION PROGRAM
WE'RE EXTREMELY GRATEFUL FOR
THE FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS INCLUDED IN THAT
PROGRAM AND LOOK FORWARD TO THE
GUIDELINES THAT WILL BE-
DRAFTED THROUGH. EACH TV AND
OUR PROCESS THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR VISION AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO IMPLEMENTING THIS IN
A WAY THAT WILL BE MOST HELPFUL
TO ALL CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. IT WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THE TIME.
THANK YOU MODERATOR NOW LET'S
COME BACK TO A THE COMMITTEE
AND WE WILL BEGIN OUR PROCESS
OF ADOPTION ON THESE- BILLS SO
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH THE
BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE
ITEM ONE A. B. ONE SIXTY FOUR
FIRST ARE THERE ANY COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS FOR TAKE EMOTION. ALL
RIGHT SEEING NINE IS THERE A
MOTION ON AB ONE SIXTY FOUR.
ALL RIGHT SENATOR EDMUND MOVED
MOVED TO ONE SIXTY FOUR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. AP ONE SIXTY
FOUR THE MOTION IS TO PASS
SENATORS SKINNER. SKINNER HI
NIELSEN. NIELSEN HI COPYRIGHT
COPYRIGHT HI CORTESE CORTESE HI
DOLLY ALI HAIDER RAZA TORONTO
HI EGGMAN A MAN I GROWTH FROM
OTHER. CAMARGO HI LAYERED.
LEHRER HI MCGUIRE. A LIAR HI
MELINDA'S. MILLION MAN HI
NEWMAN. NEWMAN HI THE TROUBLE I
TROUBLE HI. PAM HI PAM HI STERN.
STERN HI BY CAL SKI. BY CAL SKI
HI. THE PROTESTS THAT HAVE
SUFFICIENT VOTES DO WE ARE WE
EXPECTING EITHER OF THE MEMBERS
WHO- MRS GROVER IS MELINDA'S
BACK. I'M SORRY THE- SEE THAT'S
JUST NOT YOU WERE JUST A NOT
VOTING OKAY THEN OTHERWISE SIR
WE ARE A. SIXTEEN- THE BILLS
OUT NOW CHILD DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAM MAYBE. ONE THIRTY ONE.
MOVED BY DR PAN ROLL CALL.
EIGHTY ONE THIRTY ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS SENATORS
SKINNER SKINNER HI NIELSEN.
NOTHING HI COPYRIGHT COPYRIGHT
HI COURTESY CORTESE HI DOLLY.
THE RAZA. TORONTO HI ADNAN.
SEGMENT HIGH GROWTH COME LONGER
CAMARGO HI LAYERED. LEHRER HI
REQUIRE REQUIRE FIVE MELINDA'S.
MAN MAN HI NEWMAN NEWMAN HI THE
TROUBLE HI JOE BUG HI PAM ALL
RIGHT THEN I STERN. EASTERN HI
BY CAL SKI HI MICHALSKI HI ALL
RIGHT THE BILLS OUT FIFTEEN.
WE'RE GOING TO A. B. ONE THIRTY
TWO POST SECONDARY EDUCATION
MOTION BY SENATOR LAYERED. ROLL
CALL. EIGHTY ONE THIRTY TWO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS SENATORS
SKINNER HI SKINNER HI NELSON.
NELSON HI COPYRIGHT. COPYRIGHT
HI COURTESY CALL TO THE HI
DOLLY. TORONTO TORONTO HI ADNAN.
SEGMENT HIGH GROWTH CAMARGO
TAMARGO HIGHLY LAYERED. I'M A
CHOIR BLAIR I MELINDA'S LINDAS
NO MAN. MAN HI NEWMAN NEWMAN HI
THE TROUBLE HI JILL BOAK HI. I
AM HI TEN HI STERN. STERN HI
WHITE COUNTY HI MY CASKEY HI.
SO THAT SORRY. DOLLY NO RIGHT
THAT BILL IS FIFTEEN TO. IT'S
OUT. WILL NOW GO TO A. B. ONE
THREE THREE HEALTH SENATOR PAN
MOVED ON GO AHEAD WILL CALL THE
ROLL EIGHTY ONE THIRTY THREE
THE MOTION IS TO PASS SENATORS
SCANNER HI SKINNER HI NIELSEN.
YES AND NO COPYRIGHT COPYRIGHT
HI CORTESE. CORTESE HI DOLLY.
DOLLY NO THE RISER. THE RUSSELL
HI ADNAN. SEGMENT HIGH GROWTH
COM AUGER FROM LAGER HI LEHRER.
I'M A CHOIR. MARK MCGWIRE HI
MELINDA'S NOW LINDA'S NO. MAN
MAN HI NEWMAN NEWMAN HI THE
TROUBLE NO TROUBLE NO HAN HI.
TEN HI STERN. STEARN HI Y.
CASKEY HI I. CASKEY HI.
THIRTEEN FOR. THE BILL IS OUT.
THIRTEEN FOR. NOW WE'LL GO TO
AB ONE THIRTY FIVE HUMAN
SERVICES MOVED BY SENATOR PAN
STREET STOP AND SHOP PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL EIGHTY ONE THIRTY
FIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
SENATORS SKINNER. SKINNER HI
NIELSEN. NIELSEN NO COPYRIGHT
COPYRIGHT HI COURTESY. WHICH IS
THE HI DOLLY DOLLY NO THE
ROSWELL. THE ROSWELL HI ADNAN
HEY MAN HI GROWTH COMMA- I AM
LONGER HI LAYERED. LEHRER HI
MIKE WEIR HI WIRE HI MELINDA'S
NO MELINDA'S NO MAN. MAN HI
NEWMAN. SIX NEWMAN HI THE
TROUBLE. TROUBLED NOW. PENN HI.
PIN HI STERN. STERN HI WHAT
CASKEY HI I CAN SKI HI RIGHT
THERE BILL IS ABOUT THIRTEEN
FOR. AND WE WILL NOW GO TO THE
AB ONE FORTY HOUSING MOVED BY
SENATOR RECOMMEND. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL EIGHTY ONE FORTY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS SENATORS
SCANNER BY SKINNER HI NIELSEN.
NELSON HI COPYRIGHT COPYRIGHT
HI CORTESE COURTESY HI DOLLY.
THE RUSSELL TORONTO HI AIKMAN.
WHEN I GROW TOM LOGGER KAMAGRA
COD LAYER. LEHRER HI MCGUIRE.
BLEIER HI MELINDA'S- I LINDOS
HI MAN MAN HI NEWMAN NEWMAN HI
THE TROUBLE HI TROUBLE HI PENN.
PM HI STERN STERN HI WHAT
COUNTY BY MY COUNT SKI HI.
RIGHT THE FOOD IS. SIX
EIGHTEEN. RIGHT SO THE BILLS
OUT SIXTEEN EIGHTY ONE FORTY
FOUR. FINE- THAT ONE IS FINE
THE FILM AND TELEVISION TAX
CREDITS DO WE HAVE A MOTION- SO
MOVED BY- SENATOR- DRAWS A. A
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL EIGHTY ONE
FORTY FOR THE MOTION TO PASS
SENATOR SKINNER. SKINNER HI
NIELSEN. COPYRIGHT COPYRIGHT I
CORTESE COURTESY HI DOLLY DOLLY
HI THE RUSSELL RUSSELL HI ADNAN.
FIGMENT HIGH GROWTH KAMAGRA
KAMAGRA COD LAYERED LEHRER I'M
A BUYER CLAIRE HI MELINDA. MAN
MAN HI NEWMAN. NEWMAN I THE
TROUBLE I TROUBLE HI. PENN HI
TEN HI STERN. STERN HI WHAT
COUNTS HI BY CAL SKI HI THE
FOOD IS FIFTEEN THE BILL AB ONE
FORTY FOUR IS OUT NOW WE DO
EIGHTY ONE FORTY EIGHT
RESOURCES- MOTION BY SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE SKI MR STOP AND
SHOP PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
EIGHTY ONE FORTY EIGHT THE
MOTION IS TO PASS SENATOR
SKINNER HI SKINNER HI. NIELSEN
COBB NELSON HI. GABRIELLE
COPYRIGHT HI CORTESE. COURTESY
HI DOLLY DAWALY NARROW THE RAZA.
RADO HI ADNAN. SEGMENT HIGH
GROWTH. COM LOGGER MARKER HI
LAYERED. LEHRER HI AM CHOIR
CHOIR I'M LINDA THIS N. AS NO
MAN. MEN HEIGHT NEWMAN. NEWMAN
HI THE TROUBLE. PENN HI PAM HI
STERN. TURN HI Y. CALLES QUE HI
CASKEY HI. NIELSEN HI TO NARROW.
MR PRINTER THERE WAS THIRTEEN
THREE IS THAT CORRECT ALL RIGHT
SO- EIGHTY ONE FORTY EIGHT IS
OUT THIRTEEN THREE OH NOW GO TO
EIGHTY ONE FIFTY THREE SOCIAL
SERVICES MOVED BY DR SENATOR
PAN. PROCOL. EIGHTY ONE FIFTY
THREE THE MOTION IS DUE PAST
SENATORS SCANNER HI SKINNER HI
NIELSEN. I KNOW SINCE I GOT
HERE. HI CORTESE WHICH HAS THE
HI DOLLY. TORONTO THE RATHER HI
ADNAN. EGGMAN HIGH GROWTH
PROMOTER FROM EVER HI LAYERED.
LEHRER I'M ACQUIRE CHOIR HI
MELINDA'S. MAN MAN HI NEWMAN
NEWMAN HI THE TROUBLE I TROUBLE
HI PAM HI PAM HI STERN. TURN HI
WHAT COUNTS P. HI BY KATHY HI.
RIGHT THE BILLS OUT FOURTEEN NO.
FIFTEEN RIGHT THE BILLS OUT
FIFTEEN VOTES- NOW WE WILL GO
THAT G. B. ONE FIFTY THREE OF
FIFTEEN VOTES. WELL NOW GO TO
EIGHTY ONE FIFTY SIX THE
BROADBAND BILL MOTION BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. KP ONE FIFTY SIX THE
MOTION TO PASS SENATORS
SKINNER. SKINNER HI NELSON.
NELSON HI CAIRO COPYRIGHT HI
COURTESY CALL TO THE HI DOLLY.
DORADO DORADO HI ADNAN. DEGREE
IN HIGH GROWTH CONNOR ON THE
OTHER SIDE LAYERED. LEHRER HI
MCGUIRE LIAR HI MELINDA. MAN
MAN HI AM NOUMAN. WOMEN HI-
TROUBLE HI TROUBLE HI HI IN
HI STERN STERN HI WHAT COUNTS
HI MARK OWSKI HI. RIGHT THE
BILLS OUT ONE FIFTY SIX WITH
FIFTEEN VOTES NOW WE GO TO THE
AB ONE SIXTY THE DEPARTMENT OF
CANNABIS CONTROL IS THERE A
MOTION. US SENATOR AKOWSKI
MOVES AB ONE SIXTY MISTER
SECOND SHOT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. AB ONE SIXTY THE MOTION
IS TO PASS SENATOR SKINNER.
SKINNER HI NIELSEN. COPYRIGHT
COPYRIGHT HI CORTESE CORTESE HI
DOLLY. THE ONLY NARROW TO RAZA
BRAZIL HI AIKMAN. SEGMENT HIGH
GROWTH COM AUGER FROM LAGER HI
LAYERED. LAYERED HI MCGUIRE.
BLEIER I'M MELINDA'S LINDAS NO
MAN. MAN HI NEWMAN NEWMAN HI
THE TROUBLE HI GLOBAL HI PAM HI
PAM HI STERN. TURN HI WHAT CAL
SKI HI ACCOUNTS HI. NIELSEN NO.
TEN EIGHTY ONE SIXTY IS OUT
FOURTEEN THREE AND- MEMBERS-
BEFORE WE CONCLUDE I WANT I
KNOW ALL OF YOU SHARE WITH ME
YOUR PRECIADO INTO THE STAFF
WHO HAVE PINTO HAS WE HAVE
MENTIONED MANY TIMES UNTOLD
HOURS AND- THEY WILL DO YOU
GREATLY LOOK FORWARD TO THE
BREAK THAT WE WILL GIVE THEM
WHILE WE ARE NOT THERE TO- BE
BOTHERING THEM ABOUT ALL THE
DETAILS OF SUCH BILLS THOUGH WE
DO KNOW THAT THEY WILL STILL BE
WORKING SOME EVEN OVER THE
BREAK BECAUSE WE DO HAVE SOME
OTHER THINGS THAT WE WILL HAVE
TO WRAP UP. WHEN WE COME BACK
IN AUGUST AND OBVIOUSLY WE
WOULD TAKE THE STEP ON THE
FLOOR BUT STAFF YOU'VE BEEN
PHENOMENAL THANK YOU AND
MEMBERS YOUR TIME IS ALSO YOUR
CONTRIBUTIONS YOUR WORK ON THIS
PHENOMENAL GREATLY APPRECIATED
AND WITH THAT WE WILL CONCLUDE
THE SENATE BUDGET AND FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE.